und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
willkommen an diesem samstag es ist der
februar
2022 ich kann mich nicht erinnern in
über zehn jahren morgenmagazin
moderationen das wir jemals an einem
samstag moderiert hätten und das tut mir
natürlich heute aus gutem grunde das
ganze jahr aus gegebenem anlass sie
wissen ist liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer heute tag drei des krieges der
aktuell in der ukraine herrscht und man
muss auch sagen in der letzten nacht
auch wieder heftige explosionen die
sogar in der hauptstadt gemeldet wurden
wir sehen jetzt gleich bilder
morgendämmerung in kiew und
natürlich so wie in den letzten tagen es
herrscht krieg in der ukraine sehen wir
vor es gibt beschuss und es gibt truppen
die russische truppen die sich schwere
kämpfe und gefechte liefern und der
widerstand der ukrainische truppen der
schein stärker als gedacht zumindest aus
russischer perspektive
ja und die schüsse und die kämpfe vor
allen dingen auch am stadtrand von
us-präsident sie lenski hat bereits in
der nacht gesagt das schicksal das
entscheidet sich jetzt
es gibt heute natürlich auch wieder viel
zu besprechen einzuordnen es gibt zum
beispiel ein gesprächsangebot moskau und
kiew das soll stattfinden in
weißrussland aber ob es dazu kommen wird
beide seiten verhandeln noch darüber wir
schauen uns jetzt aber erst einmal die
themen im überblick an
schlacht um kiew erbitterter widerstand
in der ukrainischen hauptstadt
flüchtlingswelle warten und hoffen an
den grenzen zur ukraine und
krisengipfel die nächsten schritte von
uno und nato
viele menschen fragen sich wie es
weitergeht zumindest politisch wollen
wir das heute auch ein bisschen
sortieren mit diversen gesprächen und
zwar unter anderem mit werken ins geäst
russland politische sprecher der
fraktion von den grünen im eu parlament
selbst russland stämmiger deutschland
wir wollen ihn fragen pr mit der
aktuellen situation umgeht und wie ihr
das ganze politisch einschätzt stefan
meyer ist und später noch zugeschaltet
der csu-generalsekretär und wir haben
ein gespräch geplant mit oliver müller
von der caritas international er hat
viele mitarbeiter in der ukraine wir
werden ihn fragen wasser von dort wird
und wie eben auch humanitäre
kurzfristige hilfe für alle betroffenen
menschen aussehen kann natürlich dazu
aktuelle einschätzungen unserer
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
aus russland aus der ukraine aus
washington und anderswo jetzt die
kompakte nachrichtenlage zusammengefasst
den hot express wir begrüßen kein
service in guten morgen guten namen
schönen guten morgen je 2 und guten
morgen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer hier der überblick über die
aktuellen ereignisse in der ukraine
gehen die kämpfe weiter auch rund um die
hauptstadt kiew zu versuchen russische
truppen dort offenbar ein heizkraftwerk
und eine kaserne einzunehmen in mehreren
stadtteilen sind schüsse und explosionen
zu hören
präsidentiellen ski hatte vor einem
großangriff auf die hauptstadt gewarnt
und die bewohner zur entschlossenen
verteidigung aufzurufen der feind müsse
wo immer möglich aufgehalten werden
im un sicherheitsrat ist eine resolution
gescheitert die den angriff auf die
ukraine verurteilen sollte wie erwartet
legte russland bei der abstimmung ein
veto ein china indien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate
enthielten sich die restlichen elf
staaten stimmten für den text
die nato schickt nun teile der schnellen
eingreiftruppe in die östlichen
mitgliedsländer so will deutschland eine
kompanie in die slowakei verlegen
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg sagte
man werde alles tun um jeden verbündeten
und jeden zentimeter nato territorium zu
verteidigen
unterdessen verhandeln moskau und kiew
über direkte gespräche dabei geht es vor
allem um den ort die ukrainische
regierung lehnt den russischen vorschlag
ab sich in der belarussischen hauptstadt
minsk zu treffen nun hat sich ungarn als
gastgeber angeboten die vereinten
nationen gehen davon aus dass rund 1,8
millionen ukraine vor den kämpfen
flüchten werden innerhalb von zwei tagen
seien bereits mehr als 50.000 menschen
ins ausland geflohen die meisten nach
polen und moldau
in georgiens hauptstadt tiflis haben am
abend zehntausende gegen den russischen
einmarsch in der ukraine protestiert vor
dem regierungssitz forderten sie den
rücktritt von premier garri beispiel e
georgien hatte sich den sanktionen gegen
russland nicht angeschlossen
soweit der kurze überblick und jetzt hat
benjamin störe den ausblick aufs wetter
[Musik]
kinder keine server und guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen zum wetter wir
blicken auf den satelliten film das
hochdruckgebiet das von frankreich
weiter in unsere richtung strömt das
sorgt heute und in den kommenden tagen
für deutliche wetterberuhigung sonnig
ruhig und trocken so werden die
aussichten für die nächsten tage aber im
moment eben auch noch sehr kalt denn auf
der ostseite dieses hochdruckgebiet
fließt die kühle luft des nordens zu uns
ins land heute morgen auch noch in
verbindung mit schnee regenschauern
gerade im stau der berge richtung
erzgebirge und alpenrand ansonsten ist
es meistens trocken allerdings ist auch
nebel unterwegs die temperaturen zum
start in den tag aktuell gemessen
sonthofen im oberallgäu meldet minus
vier grad heute morgen plus vier grad
sind es im nordosten gemessen in
eberswalde und damit sind wir beim blick
auf den samstag vormittag gerade im
osten sind die wolken noch dichter dazu
der nebel und eben die abklingenden
schneeschauer richtung erzgebirge und
alpenrand von westen wird es
freundlicher im nordwesten schon am
vormittag recht starker sonnenschein zum
nachmittag dann noch mehr sonne dort und
auch im südwesten auch richtung osten
werden sich die wolken lichten und die
sonne hat mehr chancen sich blicken zu
lassen das ganze bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute zwischen
zwei grad richtung alpenrand bis 10 grad
verbreitet im nordwesten und damit sind
wir bei den aussichten für die kommenden
drei tage morgen sehr freundlich nach
nebelauflösung vier bis elf grad
ebenfalls am montag vier bis elf grad
mit viel sonnenschein am dienstag noch
eine spur milder sechs bis zwölf grad im
tagesverlauf allerdings von nordwesten
dichte wolken und schauern soweit zum
wetter für den moment kommen sie mit
diesen aussichten jetzt gut in den
samstag
[Musik]
willkommen zu diesem extra zdf
morgenmagazin an diesem samstag wir
werden noch bis 10 uhr 30 live senden ja
im russischen angriffskrieg da
konzentrieren sich die kämpfe gerade auf
die hauptstadt kiew auch in dieser nacht
also schüsse und kämpfe am straßenrand
präsident selensky rief die bewohner
inzwischen auf die stadt zu verteidigen
ja und im zusammenhang mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten seelands gibt
es eine aufsehenerregende meldung ap
meldet dass er also seelands die nach us
angaben eine aufforderung der regierung
in washington also eine aufforderung der
us regierung abgelehnt hat sich aus kiew
in sicherheit zu bringen ja und zwar
habe sie lenski ein entsprechendes
angebot mit den worten abgelehnt der
kampf ist hier ich brauche munition
keine mitfahrgelegenheit
also er ist wohl sehr sehr entschlossen
was gestern schon bekannt wurden wurde
ist das ist wohl ein gesprächsangebot
gibt putins sich mit selen ski zu
unterhalten und zwar in weißrussland
aber ob das stattfindet das steht noch
in den sternen die außenministerin
berbalk nannte dieses gesprächsangebot
vergiftet beide seiten sind wohl
anscheinend jetzt noch im gespräch sind
quasi verhandlungen über verhandlungen
denn putin stellt ganz bestimmte
bedingungen die aktuelle lage in der
ukraine die fast jetzt tim kröger für
sie zusammen
es ist später freitagabend in kiew als
die sirenen wieder zu heulen beginnen
diese männer stehen offenbar an um sich
vom militär bewaffnen zu lassen sie
wollen die ukrainische hauptstadt mit
allen mitteln verteidigen ein angriff
auf die metropole stehe unmittelbar
bevor so der ukrainische präsident
zielinsky in der nacht
wir dürfen unsere hauptstadt nicht
verlieren ich wende mich an unsere
verteidiger in dieser nacht wird unser
feind an allen fronten seine ganze kraft
einsetzen um unseren widerstand zu
brechen
bedrohlich er macht volk nicht
menschlich in dieser nacht kommt es zum
sturm
und tatsächlich scheint kiew das
hauptziel der russischen invasion zu
sein die russischen einheiten rücken vor
allem von norden an die stadt heran der
kreml wolle die ukrainische führung
ablösen und eine marionettenregierung
installieren so die lesart vieler
beobachter
am späten abend schildert ein
notfallmediziner aus kiew im zdf die
situation in der stadt erhöht man dass
geschossen wird und
man hört auch explosionen
weil wir haben einen improvisierten
bunker leider müssen die bettlägerigen
patienten in den zimmern bleiben
und wir bieten immer an den gott dass er
kein geschoss zu uns kommt ein winziger
hoffnungsschimmer vielleicht laut
facebook seite eines sprechers der
ukrainischen führung werde gerade mit
den russen über mögliche verhandlungen
verhandelt ausgang mehr als ungewiss
noch ist das die realität russische
truppen greifen die ukraine von mehreren
seiten an wenn ich aktiv etwa stellen
sich ihnen ukrainische soldaten entgegen
detonationen in der nähe angst auf den
straßen
dieser vater zeigt wie der vorhang seine
tochter vor den zersplitternden fenstern
bewahrt habe
wir mussten in der u-bahn-station
schlafen es war sehr vollen menschen das
nachspülen wir blieben an einem platz
weil dort ein süßer hund war dem mochte
ich sehr
fahrradhelme gegen bomben u bahnhöfe und
heizungskeller werden zu schutzräumen
zigtausende sehen nur noch die flucht
als ausweg die bittere realität des
krieges noch ist kiew nicht gefallen das
bangen geht weiter
eine wirklich schlimme situation in der
ukraine und natürlich ist es auch heute
das beherrschende thema in allen
tageszeitungen mit ausführlichen
analysen
beschäftigen sich dort die
schreiberinnen und schreiber und wir
wollen direkt uns jetzt mit der
situation in der ukraine beschäftigt und
dazu schalten wir jetzt zu unserer
korrespondentin katrin eigendorf die für
uns seit tagen schon in der ukraine
unterwegs ist sie befinden sich aktuell
in venezia südwestlich von der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew wie ist die
lage bei ihnen
ja auch hier wird die lage doch deutlich
gefährlicher wir haben gestern abend
mehrfach luftalarm gehabt auch heute
nacht hat es zweimal luftalarm gegeben
wir haben aus
regierungskreisen die meldung dass
anscheinend ein russischer kampfjet 30
kilometer von hier abgeschossen wurde
anscheinend ist es der ukrainischen
armee in der nacht gelungen mehrere
russische kampfjets und hubschrauber
abzuschießen
das können wir natürlich nicht
verifizieren das sind informationen aus
regierungsangaben aber wenn man sich das
bild an guckt so ist es doch so dass
der russischen armee ein wirklich
deutlicher widerstand von ukrainischer
seite entgegengesetzt wird ich denke
damit hat putin nicht gerechnet dass er
hat mir geglaubt dass er relativ schnell
hier die ukrainische hauptstadt
einnehmen kann und die regierung
absetzen kann aber die ukraine haben
sich doch als sehr sehr zäh erwiesen
zielinski hat ja noch einmal dazu
aufgerufen widerstand zu leisten und er
selber ist im prinzip in dieser krise zu
einer wirklichen
führungsfigur dieser widerstandsbewegung
geworden hat ja selber auch gesagt auch
wenn sein leben bedroht ist er wird
seine stadt er wird hilfen nicht
verlassen und einfach für sein land
einstehen es ginge um das überleben der
ukraine das ist auch die stimmung die
hier immer wieder durchdringt wenn wir
mit menschen sprechen zwar die große
sorge um die eigene zukunft und manche
verlassen auch das land vor allem frauen
und kinder aber auch eine große
entschlossenheit für das land hier
einzustehen putin wird hier mit
erheblichem widerstand rechnen müssen
wenn er mit bodentruppen auch nach kiew
geht und die wir jetzt aus
unterschiedlichen quellen als
informationen gehört haben scheint die
russische regierung inzwischen auch
tschetschenische spezialkräfte
einzusetzen kommandos die als besonders
brutal und skrupellos und trainiert
gelten die ja schon überall in der welt
auch eingesetzt wurden für
spezialoperationen die in tierversuchen
sollen die regierung zu entmachten das
ist der stand der dinge heute aus der
ukraine es ist tag drei des krieges sehr
gerade auch schon angesprochen viele
viele menschen verlassen
verständlicherweise ihr zuhause was
können sie über die fluchtbewegungen
ansonsten nach berichten
nun die leute die die flucht ergreifen
wie zum beispiel ist eine stadt die im
prinzip an die europäischen grenzen
führt zum beispiel nach rumänien aber
auch weiter nach levi hier die hotels
sind alle komplett ausgebucht viele
leute sitzen hier auf gepackten koffern
versuchen nach europa zu gehen man
spricht von circa 100.000 menschen die
sich auf die flucht gemacht haben das
ist natürlich auch nicht so einfach weil
sie müssen ja auch durch umkämpfte
gebiete das ist auch gefährlich es ist
gefährlich die stadt kiew im moment zu
verlassen auf dem landweg ist ist
gefährlich auch sich einfach auf diesen
weg zu machen von daher das lässt
natürlich viele leute auch
zurückschrecken aber wie ich vorhin
gesagt habe beobachte ich auch abgesehen
von der sorge um das eigene leben dass
viele ukrainer hier auch zusammen stehen
wollen und entschlossen sind vor allem
junge männer ihr land zu verteidigen die
können ja nun männer können ja das land
auch nicht mehr verlassen zwischen 18
und 60 müssen in der ukraine bleiben um
hier im prinzip kampf bereit zu sein ich
würde sagen die großen flüchtlingsströme
das ist noch die frage ob wir die
wirklich sehen werden aber europa muss
sich natürlich auf fluchtbewegungen aus
der ukraine in den kommenden tagen und
wochen vorbereiten katrin eigendorf
vielen dank für diese berichterstattung
aus der ukraine
also katrin eigendorf hat gerade gesagt
dass der ukrainische präsident see
lynskey sich zu einer wirklichen
führungsfigur entwickelt und das hängt
auch damit zusammen dass er immer wieder
betont im land bleiben zu wollen obwohl
die usa ihm jetzt wohl möglich ein
angebot gemacht haben sich in sicherheit
zu bringen wir wollen jetzt darüber
sprechen und zwar mit unserem
korrespondenten in washington da ist es
jetzt nachts wir begrüßen alle motive
sind hallo emma
ja schon morgen nach deutschland hallo
was können sie uns darüber sagen elmar
see lenski lehnt ein fluchthilfe angebot
der usa ab
die washington post hat gemeldet dass
tatsächlich die usa solch ein angebot an
know me als lenski gemacht hat man hat
ihnen eigentlich seite seit monaten
schon beraten was passiert eigentlich
wenn man hat ihm auch sehr bewusst
abgeraten zur münchner
sicherheitskonferenz vor einigen wochen
zu fliegen er hat es trotzdem gemacht
und jetzt gibt es eben das stehende
angebot der usa ihn zu evakuieren er hat
bisher dieses angebot abgelehnt seine
familie befindet sich an einem
unbekannten ort in sicherheit so heißt
es hier in washington aber die lenski
selber will eben vor ort bleiben um den
widerstand zu koordinieren aber die usa
haben dieses angebot eben gemacht weil
sie glauben in dem moment wo er gefangen
genommen würde wäre es für leute wie
putin einfach eben eine regierung zu
installieren ein marionettenregime
gewissermaßen deswegen ist das eine
letzte option das entstehen das angebot
wie genau das stattfinden würde das
wissen wir nicht aber
vielleicht noch ein anderes thema und
zwar zum thema sanktionen nach der eu
haben ja auch die usa weitere gegen
russland verhängt welche sanktionen sind
das was können sie bewirken
ja man hat eher symbolisch wladimir
putin seinem außenminister sergei lavrov
sowie auch den verteidigungsminister und
dem generalstabschef auf die liste der
special days awake nationals gesetzt die
stn liste bedeutet im grunde genommen
dass diese personen ihre guthaben
eingefroren bekommen in den usa sofern
sie welche abend dass keine amerikaner
und amerikanische firmen in irgendeiner
form mit ihnen geschäfte machen können
auf dieser liste stehen normalerweise
auch terroristen terrorismus
unterstützer drogendealer und andere es
steht auch baschar al assad ein
staatschef auf dieser liste drauf das
hat in diesem fall der russischen
führung eigentlich eher eine symbolische
bedeutung weil die vermögensverhältnisse
so verschachtelt sind dass es schwer ist
tatsächlich diese sanktionen auch dann
durchzusetzen oder wladimir putin so
sagt man habe überhaupt kein bankkonto
aber ist ein wichtiges signal die usa
sind auch der meinung dass man russland
vom swift internationalen banken
kommunikationssystemen ab grenzen sollte
isolieren sollte die europäer tun sich
ganz offenbar schwer mit dieser
entscheidung und solange werden die usa
die ukraine vor allen dingen finanziell
weiter unterstützen der präsident hat
350 millionen dollar direkthilfe nochmal
munition und waffen bewilligt und
obendrein 64 milliarden dollar vom
amerikanischen kongress beantragt um bei
humanitären maßnahmen für die
ukrainische bevölkerung zu unterstützen
also die usa wollen unterstützen und
helfen wo es geht danke für die
aktuellen informationen live aus
washington war dass elmar theveßen
dankeschön
ja gestern abend ein weiterer
sondergipfel der nato einheiten von der
sogenannten schnellen einsatztruppe
werden in die östlichen mitgliedsländer
verlegt übrigens zum ersten mal dass
teile dieser truppe zur abschreckung und
verteidigung des bündnisses verlegt
würden so der generalsekretär starten ja
es zeigt bei der suche nach einer
richtigen antwort aktuell geht es zum
einen darum wie tritt man nach außen
also gegenüber putin auf aber eben auch
welches signal sendet man nach innen an
die osteuropäischen bündnisstaaten
nämlich damit sie sich eben gut
geschützt fühlen um druck auf russland
auszuüben sind in dieser nacht die neuen
eu sanktionen in kraft getreten mehr
dazu erfahren wir jetzt von anne
gellinek
schon dreimal haben die europäischen
außenminister und ministerinnen in
dieser woche zusammen gesessen zwei
sanktionspaket gegen russland
beschlossen und sich dann noch wladimir
putin und sergey lavrov vorgeknöpft
neben dem belarussischen diktator ist
putin nun der einzige präsident der welt
gegen den die eu sanktionen verhängt hat
sie sind verantwortlich dafür dass
unschuldige menschen in der ukraine
sterben sie sind dafür verantwortlich
dass das internationale system mit füßen
getreten wird und das nehmen wir als
europäerinnen und europäer nicht hin
darüber hinaus beschließt die eu ihre
bislang härtesten strafmaßnahmen
ihr ziel die russische wirtschaft
langfristig zu schwächen im paket
exportkontrollen für flugzeugtechnik gas
und ölförderung high tech produkte
außerdem listet die eu drei große
russische banken die künftig keine
geschäfte mehr in europa machen sollen
putin und lavrov dürfen übrigens weiter
in die europäische union einreisen
schließlich gibt es die hoffnung
nach kriegsende wieder miteinander reden
können aber noch ist es nicht soweit
fünf kilometer vom europaviertel
entfernt krisen video konferenz der
nato-mitglieder die militärallianz
beschließt die so genannte schnelle
eingreiftruppe zu verlegen um die
ostflanke zu stärken wie fielmann und
wohin ist unklar das ziel deutlich
abschreckung
ist für uns ist wichtig dass wir ein
überschwappen des furchtbaren und
inakzeptablen angriff auf die ukraine
ein überschwappen auf einen nato partner
verhindern
und um dafür zu sorgen dass es keine
missverständnisse oder
fehleinschätzungen gibt hat die nato
ihre präsenz im östlichen teil der
allianz verstärkt mit kampftruppen die
wir an die ostflanke verlegen
draußen vorm hauptquartier demonstrieren
den ganzen tag lang menschen mit
ukrainischen fan sie wünschen sich einen
baldigen nato beitritt ihres landes die
demonstranten dürfen nur auf der anderen
straßenseite stehen die nato hält sie
wie das land auf abstand und
jetzt begrüße ich oberst andré wüstner
den vorsitzenden des deutschen
bundeswehrverbandes guten morgen
guten morgen
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht hat
gestern angekündigt dass die konsequenz
aus der russischen offensive eine
stärkung der nato ostflanke ist was
genau heißt das jetzt also wer macht
sich da jetzt wohin auf den weg
na ja es ist so dass nicht nur die nato
alarm befehle gibt sondern die werden
jetzt natürlich von den einzelnen
bündnispartnern umgesetzt auch für
deutschland das heißt wir haben einen
beitrag von circa 14.000 im bereich der
schnellen eingreifkräfte 14.000 soldatin
soldaten und die ersten machen sich
jetzt auf den weg in den nächsten tagen
in richtung slowakei aber auch weiterhin
zur verstärkung nach liter und es geht
darum die partner an der ostflanke zu
unterstützen zu stärken es geht um
brasilien zum widerstandsfähigkeit und
das ist das gebot der stunde da müssen
wir mal schauen wie gut wir dazu in der
lage sind denn laut heeresinspekteur
mais steht die bundeswehr das haben sie
mit sicherheit auch gehört mehr oder
weniger blank da der frühere nato
general egon ramms hat gesagt wir wären
nicht in der lage uns zu verteidigen wie
schlimm ist der zustand der bundeswehr
also diese aussagen die dürfen in
deutschland eigentlich keinen
überraschen denn sie über das
morgenmagazin wir auch viele zeitungen
und auch die wehrbeauftragten berichten
genau das in den letzten jahren und
deswegen ist der frust in der truppe
dahingehend auch groß und
nichtsdestotrotz sind sie hoch motiviert
ihre partner zu unterstützen und das zu
leisten was das bündnis fordert bezogen
auf die gesamt zusammensetzung des
bündnisses oder auch die kräfte in
deutschland ist es so dass wir
versäumnisse haben bei der ausrichtung
in richtung landes und
bündnisverteidigung das wurde bemängelt
wir haben im bereich munition fahrzeuge
schiffe flugzeuge ersatzteile massive
probleme nichtsdestotrotz für das was
wir angeboten haben in der nato dafür
stehen wir bereit politik muss jetzt
aber endlich aufwachen bezogen auf die
strategischen herausforderung mit blick
auf putin aber auch mit blick auf die
äußere sicherheit und auch die
bundeswehr endlich stärken für ihren
auftrag ausstatten das ist auch das
gebot der stunde dann machen sie es
vielleicht mal ganz konkret und erklären
uns was passieren muss damit das muss
sich jetzt ändern damit wir solche
situationen gerecht werden und gehört
dazu möglicherweise auch die frage
langfristig die wehrpflicht wieder
einzuführen
es geht jetzt erstmal darum das zu
unterfüttern was politik seit der
annexion der krim von der bundeswehr
verlangt zumindest auf dem papier
nämlich landes und bündnisverteidigung
wieder in den fokus zu rücken neben
einsätzen zuletzt afghanistan
abgeschlossen noch immer mali und
landes- und bündnisverteidigung ist eben
eine andere dimension und hat auch
andere erfordernisse wenn es darum geht
kampfkräftige verbände auf ebene der
brigade division geschwader flottille
wieder einsatzbereit zu machen sie
müssen ja wissen wir haben das hier
alles abgebaut mit der reform 2010 11
und jetzt geht es darum dass wieder zu
stärken weil das bündnis das braucht
weil putin als aggressor auftritt und
weil es darum geht klassisch wieder die
verteidigung auf den weg zu bringen und
das ist ein gesamtportfolio von munition
ersatzteilen waffen und gerät und
deswegen gilt es zu investieren es gibt
gilt strukturell anzupassen und es geht
auch warum diese kampfverbände endlich
wieder so zu unterfüttern wie es
notwendig ist denn es reicht eben nicht
in einem panzerbataillon das eigentlich
42 km verbraucht nur fünf drin zu haben
sondern muss endlich wieder verstärken
und das was bundeswehr leisten soll auch
entsprechend unterfüttern und das ist
das gebot der stunde dieser
bundesregierung in diesem jahr braucht
es ein sofortprogramm ist braucht ein
anstieg des verteidigungshaushaltes
warten ist nicht mal mehr die zweitbeste
option sie wissen das ist immer wieder
die frage nach waffenlieferungen gibt
wie sich die bundesregierung dazu
positioniert bislang bleibt sie ja beim
strikten nein ganz traditionell wie es
ihre einstellung dazu wären sie dafür
dass wir in die ukraine waffen liefern
naja die verteidigungsminister hatte er
im zuge der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz sehr klar zum
ausdruck gebracht dass die bundeswehr
selbst seine grenzen ihrer
leistungsfähigkeit und auch ihre vorräte
ist also muss ja schon zum ausdruck
bringen dass die depots nicht mehr voll
sind und wir können ja nicht das liefert
was wir selbst nicht haben deswegen gilt
es gesamt eben jetzt zu verstärken
wiederzubeschaffen helme schutzweste
funkgeräten 18 geräte aber eben auch
großgerät und wir das wenn wir das haben
können wir natürlich auch liefern aber
das muss man immer im gesamtzusammenhang
sehen auch mit blick auf die
waffenlieferungen in richtung ukraine
sagt der vorsitzende des deutschen
bundeswehrverbandes
oberst andré wüstner ganz herzlichen
dank für das interview
dann geben sie
so dann machen wir jetzt mal weiter und
sagen normal einen schönen guten morgen
an diesen
[Musik]
heute im studio jetzt gehört von
waldenfels und mitri sirin
einen guten tag an diesem samstagmorgen
es ist eine extra ausgabe des
morgenmagazins den aktuellen ereignissen
geschuldet wir sind noch bis 10 uhr 30
leit und wollen diese halbe stunde mit
bildern beginnen die uns aktuell aus
kiew erreichen denn dort sehen wir einen
brand in der ukrainischen hauptstadt das
ganze in der gegend rund um den zoo in
kiew und die aufnehmer aufnahmen wurden
geteilt von ja bewohnerinnen und
bewohnern der hauptstadt über twitter um
die welt in gewisser weise auch
teilhaben zu lassen an diesem krieg und
zu zeigen was dort passiert ja es werden
mehrere explosionen berichtet aus der
ukrainischen hauptstadt wo sich die
kämpfe jetzt wohl konzentrieren es gibt
schwere gefechte zwischen beiden seiten
unter anderem in der nähe der u
bahnstation
kann ich leider gar nicht aussprechen
die cd namen des tsk jahr heißt es
glaube ich jedenfalls ist es eine
schwere
sind gibt es schwere kämpfe rund um die
hauptstadt kiew und dazu werden wir mit
unseren korrespondentinnen und
korrespondenten sprechen aber auch
natürlich haben wir da zu viele
politische gespräche und dazu werfen wir
im blick auf unsere gesprächs tafel mit
den gesprächen die wir vorbereitet haben
unter anderem sprechen wir heute mit
sergey lagodinsky er ist der russland
politische sprecher der grünen fraktion
im eu parlament selbst russland
stämmiger deutscher deutscher und wir
wollen ihn fragen wie er mit dieser
situation aktuell umgeht und wie das
ganze politisch einzuordnen ist dazu
auch später noch zugeschaltet der csu
generalsekretär stephan mayer und später
sprechen wir noch mit oliver müller von
der caritas international über mögliche
humanitäre hilfe für die menschen in der
ukraine
wie kann man ihnen helfen
das hört er auch von seinem
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern von
vor ort und interessantes gespräch dass
du gerade geführt hast mit dem
vorsitzenden des bundeswehrverbandes mit
andré wüstner der gesagt hat dass ihnen
diese ganze diskussion natürlich
überhaupt gar nicht überrascht der
fähigkeit der bundeswehr und
selbstverteidigung das hat er und das
beklagt er seit jahren und hat im grunde
zwischen der zahlen gesagt dass die
politik das einfach verschlafen hat wir
machen jetzt weiter mit den nachrichten
kompakt zusammengefasst von kai soll
berichten heute express hallo guten
morgen
guten morgen zurück und guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer hier
als die ereignisse in der
zusammenfassung in der ukraine gehen die
kämpfe weiter auch rund um die
hauptstadt kiew zu versuchen russische
truppen dort offenbar ein heizkraftwerk
und eine kaserne einzunehmen in mehreren
stadtteilen sind schüsse und explosionen
zu hören präsident sie lenski hatte vor
einem großangriff auf die hauptstadt
gewarnt und die bewohner zur
entschlossenen verteidigung aufgerufen
der feind müsse wo immer möglich
aufgehalten werden
im un sicherheitsrat ist eine resolution
gescheitert die den angriff auf die
ukraine verurteilen sollte wie erwartet
legte russland bei der abstimmung ein
veto ein china indien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate
enthielten sich die restlichen elf
staaten stimmten für den text
die nato verstärkt ihre ostflanke weiter
und schickt teile der schnellen
eingreiftruppe in die dortigen
mitgliedsländer so will deutschland eine
kompanie in die slowakei verlegen
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg sagte
man werde alles tun um jeden verbündeten
und jeden zentimeter nato gebiet zu
verteidigen
unterdessen verhandeln moskau und kiew
über direkte gespräche dabei geht es vor
allem um den ort die ukrainische
regierung lehnt den russischen vorschlag
ab sich in der belarussischen hauptstadt
minsk zu treffen nun hat sich ungarn als
gastgeber angeboten
in georgiens hauptstadt tiflis haben am
abend zehntausende gegen den russischen
einmarsch in die ukraine protestiert sie
forderten den rücktritt von premier gar
evers willi dessen regierung hatte sich
den sanktionen gegen russland nicht
angeschlossen
schauen wir noch aufs thema corona denn
heute starten in drei bundesländern
impfungen mit dem wachsen von nowaks in
hamburg schleswig-holstein und dem
saarland soll es vorrangig beschäftigten
im gesundheitswesen angeboten werden
dort gilt ab dem 15 märz eine
einrichtung bezogene impfpflicht als
sogenannter proteinen impfstoff soll
nowaks denjenigen eine alternative
bieten die der m rna technologie
skeptisch gegenüberstehen
wettermäßig verspricht das wochenende
ein paar lichtblicke benjamin stufe hat
die aussichten
[Musik]
vielen dank server und guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen zum wetter in der
tat der hochdruckeinfluss der nimmt in
den nächsten tagen zu allerdings gerade
heute morgen nebel im westen hochnebel
im osten da kann es noch mal glatt seien
auf den strassen vorsicht wenn sie sich
jetzt auf den weg machen aber der
vorschau film zeigt uns wie sich dieses
hochdruckgebiet von westen kommend bei
uns ausbreitet und damit die
tiefdruckgebiete auf abstand hält
allerdings auch an der ostseite dieses
hochdruckgebiet fließt noch mal kühle
luft zu uns ins land es ist eben doch
recht frisch heute morgen sogar frostig
minus vier grad haben wir richtung
südschwarzwald und bei schnee
regenschauern die im moment im stau der
alpen und auch richtung erzgebirge
verklingen eben obacht auf den straßen
hier sind die aktuell gemessenen
temperaturen heute morgen todtmoos im
südschwarzwald wie angesprochen minus
vier grad plus fünf grad sind es auf
norderney das ist die spanne die den tag
eröffnet minus vier bis plus 5 und hier
ist der vormittag im überblick im osten
sind die wolken noch dichter die
schneeregenschauer im stau der berge
verklingen im nordwesten lässt sich am
ehesten intensiv die sonne blicken und
von dort aus können sie sich dann im
tagesverlauf auch auf den anderen
landesteilen annähern und durchsetzen am
meisten noch im südwesten und auch im
osten werden sich zum nachmittag die
wolken lichten das ganze bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute zwischen 2
grad am alpenrand bis 10 grad verbreitet
im nordwesten und damit sind wir bei den
ebenfalls hochdruck geprägten aussichten
für die kommenden drei tage morgen sehr
freundlich nach nebelauflösung vier bis
elf grad das gleiche gilt für den montag
am dienstag allerdings dann im
tagesverlauf dichte wolken und regen von
nordwesten und auch noch mal eine spur
milder sechs bis zwölf grad so weit zum
wetter für den moment kommen sie mit
diesen aussichten jetzt gut in den
samstag
[Musik]
willkommen zum zdf morgenmagazin in
einer extra ausgabe
noch nie haben wir eigentlich zumindest
in meiner erinnerung an einem samstag
gesendet und zwar noch bis 10 uhr 30
live alle informationen und ereignisse
rund um den krieg in der ukraine
die invasion der russischen streitkräfte
schreitet voran ist konzentriert sich
viel auf den kampf um die ukrainische
hauptstadt gerade und es gibt natürlich
auch verschiedene informationen von
beiden seiten ist schon eine
propagandaschlacht ist interessant
agiert was der ukrainische präsident
gerade an seine bevölkerung gesagt hat
gerichtet hat guten morgen ukrainer
glauben sie den falschmeldungen nicht es
gibt keine kapitulation wir verteidigen
unser land niemand wird die waffen
niederlegen und wenn er das sagt dann
kann man sich vorstellen was in moskau
verbreitet wird denn eine kapitulation
war ja die bedingungen für putin
überhaupt noch einmal gespräche zu
beginnen und das haben sie vielleicht
auch schon mitbekommen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer da gibt es
widersprüchliche meldungen darüber ob
und wenn ja unter welchen bedingungen
eventuell doch noch gespräche zwischen
beiden seiten stattfinden können dazu
fragen wir jetzt nach bei unserer
korrespondentin direkt live in moskau
und zwar bei anna falls putin hat ja
gesprächsbereitschaft signalisiert unter
bestimmten bedingungen wie ich gerade
gesagt habe wie ernst kann man das denn
nehmen
ja diese gesprächsbereitschaft
signalisiert putin schon seit dem ersten
tag des krieges also schon seit
donnerstag da gab es eine meldung dass
der belarussische präsident lukaschenka
anbietet für friedensgespräche min zur
verfügung zu stellen lukaschenka hätte
sich wohl mit mit putin kurzgeschlossen
und eben beide hätten vereinbart dass
dieser krieg zu beenden sei mit
friedensgesprächen zwischen der ukraine
und russland und minsk stünde als ort
zur verfügung die bedingung sei aber
ganz klar dass die ukraine weiterhin ab
brücke von einer nato-mitgliedschaft und
dass die ukraine komplett
entmilitarisiert wird und diese
gesprächsbereitschaft russland wurde
dann donnerstag den ganzen tag von
verschiedenen sprechern und ministern
der russischen regierung immer wieder
lanciert und nun eben auch gestern am
freitag selensky barth ja um ein
gespräch die antwort aus russland
erfolgte prompt man würde dieses
gespräch gerne eben in minsk führen
putin habe dann wohl auch sofort zum
telefonhörer gegriffen und sofort
lukaschenka angerufen sie hatten
vereinbart dass die gespräche in minsk
stattfinden können doch dann hätte sie
lenski gesagt er würde lieber in
warschau verhandeln und dann so die rot
das russische narrativ sei sie denn es
ging nicht mehr ans telefon gegangen das
ist das was hier verbreitet wird wie
dieser dialog aussehen kann oder auch
nicht und abgesehen jetzt von dem
inhaltlichen hört man ja auch mal ganz
genau hin wie der russische präsident
etwas sagt also die betonung auf wer
etwas sagt dann putin hat die ukraine
als bande von drogenabhängigen und
neonazis bezeichnet warum spricht also
ja die ukraine als bande von
drogenabhängigen zu bezeichnen auch das
ist
eine alte propaganda die ich hier schon
seit jahren seitdem sie lenski präsident
ist läuft die unterstellung die dahinter
steckt ist das selensky kokain abhängig
sei man müsste sich doch nur mal
seelands kies augen angucken und die
augenringe da sie jemand doch dass
dieser mann kokain abhängig sei und
insofern nicht ernst zu nehmen außerdem
sei selensky ein schwacher charakter der
manipuliert würde von ultranationalisten
das ist die staatspropaganda die ich
hier schon aber seit jahren vorherrscht
und auf die eben diese beiden termine
ziehen anna faißt war das mit aktuellen
informationen aus moskau auf vielen dank
das mächtigste gremium der vereinten
nationen ist wieder für eine
krisensitzung zusammengekommen natürlich
um darüber zu beraten wie es da jetzt
weitergehen soll der un sicherheitsrat
und um genau dafür zu sorgen nämlich für
internationale sicherheit und frieden
kann er resolutionen verabschieden also
das bedeutet für alle bindende
forderungen nur es gibt halt vetomächte
die das verhindern können zum beispiel
china oder russland selbst russland hat
das wir erwartet getan ein veto
eingelegt china hat sich enthalten und
sich kritisch zu dem krieg geäußert aus
new york mehr von johannes hano
es war eine geste der solidarität als
ich kurz vor der sitzung des un
sicherheitsrates die botschafter der
europäischen union hinter ihrem
ukrainischen kollegen und seiner fahne
versammelten schon dabei klar dass es
eine außergewöhnliche sitzung werden
würde die usa in albanien hatten eine
resolution zur abstimmung eingebracht
die den russischen angriffskrieg in der
ukraine verurteilt aber es ging um sehr
viel mehr
ich sage es ganz offen stimmt mit ja
mini die charta der vereinten nationen
aufrechterhalten wollen wenn ihr die
souveränität und die territoriale
integrität der ukraine und die jeden
anderen staates unterstützt wenn ihr
überzeugt seid dass russlands für sein
handeln zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
muss stimmt mit nein oder enthalten euch
wenn ihr nicht hinter der charta der
vereinten nationen steht und euch gemein
macht mit dem aggressiven und
provozierten handeln russlands
russland das war klar würde die
resolution mit einem veto belegen
russlands botschafter bezichtigte den
westen der lüge und der propaganda
russische truppen bombardieren keine
ukrainischen städte wir haben gesagt
dass sie nicht bedroht sind es gibt
keine verifizierbare bestätigung über
den tod von zivilisten
die frage war wer wird russland
unterstützen und gegen die resolution
stimmen oder sich enthalten immer wieder
wurde die sitzung verschoben wollten die
usa und andere china und indien
überzeugen der resolution zuzustimmen
ohne erfolg indien die vereinigten
arabischen emirate und china enthielten
sich der stimme
die legitimen sicherheitsbedenken aller
staaten müssen berücksichtigt werden
vor dem hintergrund von fünf
erweiterungs wohnten der nato richtung
osten muss man verstehen dass russlands
sicherheitsbedenken berücksichtigt
werden müssen
wir bedanken uns bei denen die diese
resolution nicht unterstützt haben elf
jahre stimmen 3 enthaltungen und einer
gegenstimme für die vereinten nationen
und die weltordnung diese repräsentieren
eine zäsur denn das ergebnis macht eines
klar ein völkerrechtswidriger
angriffskrieg wird im sicherheitsrat
nicht mehr von allen staaten abgelehnt
am ende der sitzung bat die ukraine um
eine gedenk minute für die opfer des
krieges unterbrochen vom russischen
botschafter und mit applaus bedacht von
der mehrheit der anwesenden vertreter
und beobachtet hat die sondersitzung des
un-sicherheitsrats johannes hano für uns
live aus new york jetzt zugeschaltet
russland hat wie erwartet ein veto
eingelegt die resolution ist damit
gescheitert dennoch ein historisches
ereignis
naja es war auf jeden fall ein
bedeutungsvolles ereignis muss man sagen
wenn es stand eine ganze menge auf dem
spiel nämlich ob die alte weltordnung
noch bestand hat oder ob sie anfängt zu
brücken und das muss man vor dem
hintergrund sehen dass die vereinten
nationen gegründet worden sind aus dem
grund nach dem grollen des zweiten
weltkriegs in vier millionen toten hat
sich die vereinten haben sich die
vereinten nationen gegründet um sich
ganz klar zum ziel zu setzen dass solche
kriege verhindert werden müssen in der
zukunft und alle mitgliedstaaten haben
sich darauf verpflichtet auf
angriffskriege zu verzichten und die
territoriale integrität und souveränität
aller mitgliedstaaten zu achten und das
hat heute auch die amerikanische
botschafterin als sie die resolution
eingebracht hat ganz klar gesagt es geht
ja heute darum klipp und klar und eine
ganz schlichte frage sind die mitglieder
des sicherheitsrates die auf deren
aufgabe es ist diese den weltfrieden
herzustellen stehen die noch hinter der
charta der vereinten nationen oder nicht
und insofern war das abstimmungsergebnis
dann doch sehr interessantes länder
haben für diese resolution gestimmt aber
eben auch drei haben sich enthalten
nämlich china indien die beiden
atommächte und
die vereinigten arabischen emirate dass
russland neu sagt war klar aber es hat
heute ziemlich klage ist ziemlich klar
geworden muss man sagen dass es eben
wichtige länder in dieser welt gibt die
einen angriffskrieg nicht mehr ablehnen
als mittel der politik das muss man so
sagen glaube ich ja ich möchte noch mal
nachfragen dass china sich enthalten hat
werden viele im westen als erfolg
russland diplomatisch zu isolieren wie
deutlich hat sich china denn geäußert
und wie hat russland das auch
aufgenommen
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
sehe das anders und ich habe auch andere
stimmen dazu gehört ein erfolg was ist
ein erfolg dass es ein erfolg dass ein
land seinem auto an einem angriffskrieg
nicht mehr zustimmt oder ist es ein
erfolg wenn ein land ein angriffskrieg
nicht ablehnt und genau das hat ja die
enthaltung gezeigt china hat den
angriffskrieg nicht abgelehnt so wie es
die resolution fordert sondern china hat
gesagt es geht vielleicht ein bisschen
weit was ihr da gerade macht aber
grundsätzlich verstehen wenn die
sicherheitsinteressen russlands und was
china gemacht hat ist es hat sich
abgewendet von seiner alten strategie
die alte strategie war immer
nichteinmischung in andere länder das
war die grund mag sie mit chinesischer
außenpolitik auch hier bei den vereinten
nationen man hat er immer verurteilt
weil sich länder in die inneren
angelegenheiten anderer länder
eingemischt haben das hat china heute
nicht gemacht im gegenteil
china hat letztlich die argumentation
russlands übernommen hat gesagt man
müsse die russischen interessen
verstehen und hat den krieg nicht
abgelegt insofern weiß ich nicht ob das
wirklich ein erfolg ist ich glaube er
nicht johannes hano vielen dank für
diese einordnungen auch die erklärung
aus new york dankeschön
wir fassen an diesem morgen weiter die
lage für sie zusammen versuchen so
aktuell so umfassend wie möglich auf die
ereignisse zu reagieren die kämpfe
finden natürlich unverhohlen weiterstadt
die russischen streitkräfte greifen das
land von 3 flanken aus an von osten von
süden und von norden und momentan
konzentriert sich vieles auf die
hauptstadt und es ist spektakulär was
wir soeben oder vor einer halben stunde
erfahren haben nämlich dass der
ukrainische präsident ein hilfsangebot
der usa aus geschlagen hat das land zu
verlassen er will weiterkämpfen für
seinem für sein land und seine
landsleute und im land bleiben wir
wollen über diese aktionen jetzt
sprechen und zwar politisch mit ist
sergej lagutin ski er ist russland
politischer sprecher der grünen im
europaparlament einen schönen guten
morgen herr lagodinsky gut nur sie sind
russland stämmiger deutscher sie sind
mitte der 70er jahre in russland geboren
wie geht es ihnen angesichts der
aktuellen situation
ich bin beschämt ich bin frustriert wie
sehr viele die russland ständig sind
hier und wie sehr viele hier sagen wir
dass das nicht der krieg der russischen
bevölkerung ist das hören wir auch von
vielen das haben wir auch gesehen auf
den straßen sehr viele sind auf die
straßen gegangen in russland wurden auch
verhaftet und mehr als 2000 leute
zurzeit in haft gewesen nur weil sie
dagegen protestiert haben gegen diesen
krieg und wie ist die situation für die
kritiker die sie gerade angesprochen
haben von putin was hören sie aus
russland vielleicht von freunden von
verwandten
es ist nicht einfach es war aber auch
nie einfach das ist ja etwas was wir
auch als deutsche politikerinnen immer
gesagt haben die
situation im inneren von russland hat
nichts mehr mit mit demokratie zu tun
und egal zu welchem anlass man darf
nicht mehr auf straßen offen
demonstrieren jetzt wollen viele
demonstrieren und das können sie nicht
weil es einfach
widerrechtlich dort noch tatsächlich
möglich ist herr lagodinsky zur
politischen dimension dieses
angriffskrieges wir waren im gespräch
vor zwei tagen mit robert habeck der zu
mir sagt im interview wir waren zu naiv
haben wir putin unterschätzt dass auch
ihre auffassung ich glaube dass sehr
viele die die entwicklungen in russland
genau verfolgt haben auch bei uns in der
partei bei den grünen wir haben immer
schon davor gewarnt auch die jetzige
außenministerin war ganz klar bei vielen
themen aber wir insgesamt als
gesellschaft in der tat wir haben eine
hoffnung immer gehabt und ich würde das
vielleicht nicht mal naiv nennen sondern
aus der erfahrung dieser unsere
gesellschaft heraus ist es schwer
vorstellbar aus der jetzigen erfahrungen
man sagen dass eben ein land einen krieg
gegen ein nachbarland mitten in europa
führt natürlich mit ausnahme der
balkankriege in der 90er aber das ist
etwas was wir vielleicht überdenken
müssen wir sind in der tat das ist ja
mittlerweile eine floskel in einer neuen
realität zur zeit und es geht nicht mehr
nur um einen angriff gegen den
europäischen frieden das haben wir ja
die tage auch gesagt sondern es geht
auch um an notwendigkeit der
verteidigung des europäischen friedens
und das muss unsere haltung sein unsere
haltung auch gegenüber unseren
ukrainischen
freundinnen und freunden es ist eine
neue brutale realität nicht nur für die
gesellschaft sondern eben auch für die
politik insofern kommen wir zu
konsequenzen waffenlieferungen wurden
die ganze zeit gefordert von seiten der
ukraine wir kennen die argumente
deutschlands warum dies nicht erfolgte
dann gab es sanktionen großflächig und
scharfe sanktionen auf europäischer
ebene
und die ukraine sagt jetzt kriegt doch
bitte wenigstens swift hin also die
abkopplung vom internationalen
transaktions system um russland zu
treffen auch das lehnt deutschland ab
wie stehen sie dieser angelegenheit
gegenüber
in dieser aufgeheizten situation
berechtigter und nachvollziehbarer weise
gibt es bestimmte themen bestimmte
lösungen auf die man sich sehr
fokussiert und konzentriert mal waren
das die waffenlieferung jetzt ist das
trifft ich glaube wir müssen das
dahinterstehende ziel verstehen und
verfolgen es geht darum jetzt sehr
schwerer schwerwiegende sanktionen gegen
die russische regierung ging das land
muss man auch sagen
zu verhängen welcher art das ist die
frage der expertinnen und experten auch
in unseren ministerien und unserem
bundes ris bundesregierung und wichtig
ist eben sind harte sanktionen gegen
russische banken um das bankensystem da
gibt es verschiedene wege es gibt zum
beispiel wege die der amerikanische
regierung geht dass sie
die korrespondenz konnten für alle oder
für die meisten russische banken einfach
verbieten im ausland das trifft
russisches banksystem genauso wenn nicht
stärker als schrift diesen weg könnte
man zum beispiel auch gehen und diese
alle wege
beschreiten wir das ist ja nicht so dass
die eu nichts tut und diese
bundesregierung nichts tut ja wir werden
nächste woche in europäischen parlament
eine sondersitzung zu diesem thema haben
und ich weiß ganz genau dass da eine
mehrheit dafür sein wird dass diese
sanktion härter sein müssen ich glaube
die bundesregierung nimmt es auch ernst
wir sind ja auch in kontakt und in
gesprächen und diese bundesregierung
sucht weiterhin nach wegen sanktionen zu
verhängen die der russischen regierung
ganz klar machen es muss auch wehtun
alles hat konsequenzen das wird
hoffentlich auch passieren in den
nächsten schritten der kanzler hat er
auch gesagt dass auch swift oder auch
andere maßnahmen immer noch nicht
ausgeschlossen sind vielen dank für ihre
zeit heute morgen das war der russland
politische sprecher der grünen im
europaparlament sergey lagodinsky vielen
dank an den
und liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
an dieser stelle möchten wir ihnen ein
statement
vorspielen von ukrainische präsident
seelands geht das uns in diesen minuten
erreicht hat er selbst hat es auf den
sozialen netzwerken veröffentlicht und
sagt das ist jetzt sinngemäß übersetzt
guten morgen ukraine glauben sie den
fälschungen nicht es gibt keine
kapitulation
wir verteidigen unser land niemand wird
die waffen niederlegen es geht um unsere
wahrheit um unsere kinder um unsere
ukraine
das möchte ich euch sagen
dann haben wir ja schon mit diversen
menschen heute morgen über diesen
konflikt gesprochen politikern aber eben
auch mit dem vorsitzenden des
bundeswehrverbandes und wollen jetzt
einmal die journalistische perspektive
eine spezielle journalistische
perspektive auf dieses thema bringen und
zwar von einer ukrainischen journalisten
die für den privatsender in kiew 1&1 tv
arbeitet natalia fiebrig einen schönen
guten morgen herzlich willkommen guten
morgen bis gestern berichteten sie als
auslandskorrespondent für den
ukrainischen sender 1&1 ich sage bis
gestern weil ihr sender dann aufhören
musste zu senden bitte erzählen sie uns
was passiert ist und auch wie es ihren
kolleginnen und kollegen geht
mein sender sendet heute noch gearbeitet
meine kollegen arbeiten weiter
die haben die arbeit
angefangen mit einer ununterbrochenen
sind und mit der spezialsendung zwei
stunden nach dem angriff der russische
angriff ist am 24 februar um 4 uhr
morgens erfolgt und bereits zwei stunden
später waren meine kollegen auf sendung
jetzt müssen wir ab und zu unterbrechen
wenn die sirenen heulen das passiert
sehr oft jetzt leiter und die müssen
dann sofort in den bunker oder sofort zu
rinnen parkhaus es wird auch jetzt daran
gearbeitet dass man möglicherweise ein
reserven studio hat dass man in einem
bunker baut und man wirklich versucht
ununterbrochen zu berichten und das
passiert heute noch was können sie von
ihren männlichen kollegen berichten
mussten die sich melden und den
streitkräften inzwischen sogar schon
anschließend denn wir wissen männer
zwischen 18 und 60 jahren dürfen die
ukraine derzeit ja auch gar nicht
verlassen
ganz viele meine männlichen kollegen
arbeiten weiterhin die sind aber bereit
wenn es notwendig ist einen kampf zu
ziehen und die stadt zu verteidigen das
land zu verteidigen ich bin sehr froh
dass meine heimatstadt kiew die sehr
schweren kämpfe statt gehalten hatte und
ja und dass es noch nicht besetzt ist
dass man wirklich geschafft hat diese
nacht zu überleben die stadt steht da
und die ukrainische
kämpfe aber auch meine ja meine ganz
viele bekannten meine kollegen aus kiel
sind bereit wenn nötig in den kampf zu
ziehen es sind jetzt auch aber mehr also
wir wären froh wenn da vielleicht ein
oder zwei
moderatoren im studio erscheint aber
eher sind mehr gekommen also wir sind
wir sind so flexibel wie möglich nicht
alle kollegen können jetzt arbeiten ganz
viele
versuchen ihre kinder in sicherheit zu
bringen in richtung westen der ukraine
aber
ganz viele anderen sind bereit und
arbeiten weiter weil das es auch
informationskrieg das sind ganz ganz
viele fakes und
dazu möchte ich noch mal nachfragen denn
auch für uns ist es auch schwierig an
informationen überhaupt zu kommen und
die dann auch zu verifizieren vielleicht
können sie uns noch kurz was über die
medienlandschaft in der ukraine erzählen
gibt es da beispielsweise auch pro
russische sender
es gibt da verschiedene center die ganz
unterschiedliche berichten aber was
jetzt in der ukraine der fall ist dass
man wirklich versucht die kräfte zu
bündeln
man versucht jetzt mit den anderen
sender ein stream eine ununterbrochene
sendung zu haben
wenn einer zb ausfällt damit der andere
dann einspringt und die großen
medienhäuser
vereinen sich damit man ununterbrochen
die berichterstattung hat zum beispiel
mainzer wenn wir jetzt nicht sagen
können dann übernehmen wie das signal
von einem anderen sender der bereits aus
dem bunker
natalia fiebrig war das ukrainische
journalistin von 1&1 tv dem privatsender
in kiew wir wünschen ihnen alles gute
und vielen dank für ihre zeit heute
morgen danke ihnen
wir machen hier im studio weiter mit
unterstützung stück sing ist auch wie
wir meinen natürlich unterstützung und
bei uns ist jetzt christian mölling er
ist der direktor des
forschungsinstitutes von d&g ap der
deutschen gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik sicherheitspolitik außenpolitik
das ist ihr feld wir schauen mal auf den
konflikt selber vielleicht so mutmaßt
man dachte der russische präsident putin
das geht jetzt ruckzuck wir marschieren
da rein von drei franken aus und haben
das land ruckzuck eingenommen es sieht
nicht danach aus wie beurteilen sie die
situation also erstmal haben das ja eben
auch schon gehört die information die
wir da rauskommen aus dem land sind
stückchen haften wir wissen nicht so
ganz genau welchen informationen
wirklich vertrauen können man kann
insgesamt immer sagen hat so etwas wie
den den nebel des krieges informationen
aber auch wahrheit sind sehr rar in
solchen in solchen lagen aber in der tat
kann man sagen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
dass die ukraine zeigt dass es nicht nur
auf anzahl von soldaten ankommen so auf
die frage von moral und dass man in der
lage ist offensichtlich den russischen
vormarsch zu verlangen sagen ob das
jetzt dazu führt dass man das über
wochen hinweg kann und damit seine
verhandlungsposition verbessert das ist
glaube ich noch eine offene frage
darüber kann man zurzeit nur was sagen
wenn man eine gute glaskugel hat es gibt
eine art gesprächsangebot muss man sagen
seitens putins das laut annalena
baerbock vergiftet ist wie ernst kann
man eine solche solches gesprächsangebot
nehmen wie schätzen sie das ein ich
glaube man muss hier ganz klar sagen die
bedingungen genannt worden sind machen
das eigentlich zu der aufforderung zu
einer kapitulation das ist keine
verhandlung sondern das ist die pistole
am kopf und sie unterschreiben unter den
bedingungen haben sie ein angebot das er
nicht ablehnen können aber das ist keine
faire verhandlung ja also von daher hat
frau berbalk total recht das ist ein
vergiftetes angebot und zielt wiederum
darauf bei uns in deutschland die
diskussion über verhandlungen zu haben
denn das ist ja eine rhetorik die wir
hier immer wieder gehört haben die
russen sind verhandlungsbereit wir
müssen wir weiter verhandeln dann würde
es passieren was die ereignisse der
letzten drei tage komplett ausblendet
sie haben die ereignisse sicherlich
verfolgt der sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen ist gestern nach
zusammengekommen an wollte was auf den
weg bringen diese resolution eben und da
gibt es eben diese ständigen mitglieder
im sicherheitsrat veto mächte china
gehört dazu china spielt eine
schlüsselrolle in diesem konflikt und
hat sich enthalten
wie lesen sie das er ist glaube ich eine
eigentlichen dramatische situation das
klingt jetzt ein bisschen komisch weil
die dramatische situation eigentlich in
der ukraine ist aber in der tat hier
wird ja sozusagen das recht verhandelt
und die regeln verhandelt an die die
gesamte welt sich eigentlich halten soll
und halten will das haben sie alle
unterschrieben und das an dem punkt wo
ich ganz klar sagen können wer der
aggressor ist dieser angriffskrieg nicht
verurteilt wird ist eine schwächung der
vereinten nationen und damit des
globalen systems der globalen normen und
regeln die wir uns eigentlich alle
halten wollten das ist mit blick auf die
frage wie wollen wir eigentlich in
zukunft weiterhin zusammenleben nicht
nur in europa sondern weltweit
tatsächlich stellt ist ein großes
fragezeichen hinter die globale aber
auch die europäische sicherheits orten
christian mölling für den augenblick
bedanken wir uns für ihre expertise sie
stehen uns aber den herr morgen über
weiter zur verfügung und nachher gehen
wir weiter in den analysen für den
augenblick und
jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio variiert von waldenfels
und mitri sirin und auch an diesem
samstagmorgen um kurz vor acht größen
wir sie außerplanmäßig zu einer ausgabe
des morgenmagazins angesicht angesichts
der aktuellen ereignisse in dieser welt
eine weitere schwere kriegs nacht liegt
hinter uns es gibt aktuelle bilder es
brennt in der ukrainischen hauptstadt
das ist die gegend um den zoo in kiew
aufgeteilt wurden diese aufnahmen von
bewohnern der hauptstadt und man sieht
diverse solcher videos über twitter das
kann man also quasi den krieg live mit
verfolgen wir die sozialen netze schüsse
und straßenkämpfe zudem vor allen dingen
am stadtrand von kiew heftige
explosionen auch und straßenkämpfe in
einem orden 40 kilometer südlich von
kiew dort gibt es nämlich einen
luftwaffenstützpunkt den russische
truppen dem anschein nach mit
fallschirmjägern erobern wollten
gespräche analysen einschätzungen zur
situation heute den ganzen morgen bis 10
uhr 30 bei uns wir schauen uns jetzt
nochmal gemeinsam die themen im
überblick an
lacht um kiew erbitterter widerstand in
der ukrainischen hauptstadt
flüchtlingswelle warten und hoffen an
der grenze zur ukraine und
krisengipfel die nächsten schritte von
uno und nato
der 10 überblick mit allen verschiedenen
aspekten die wir heute beleuchten wollen
wir haben dazu natürlich auch jede menge
gespräche geplant sergey lagodinsky war
uns schon zugeschaltete russland
politische sprecher der grünen fraktion
im eu parlament gleich sprechen wir noch
mit dem 90 und generalsekretär stefan
meyer und ein gespräch ist auch geplant
mit oliver müller von caritas
international über mögliche kurzfristige
humanitäre hilfe für die menschen im
land und wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf
wir haben relativ spontan doch noch eine
zusage bekommen zu einem gespräch mit
litauens präsident das freut uns sehr
lettlands präsident entschuldigung und
das wird auch in ungefähr zehn minuten
hier stattfinden jetzt gehen wir über zu
kann soll richter mit heute express
hallo
hallo zurück und guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir schauen
zunächst auf die situation in der
ukraine wo auch rund um die hauptstadt
kiew gekämpft wird nach behördenangaben
gibt es in mehreren stadtteilen
straßenkämpfe mit russischen truppen die
bevölkerung soll schutzräume aussuchen
und dort bleiben die ukrainische armee
berichtet auch von gefechten an einer
militärischen einrichtung westlich von
kiew
im un-sicherheitsrat ist eine resolution
gescheitert die den angriff auf die
ukraine verurteilen sollte wie erwartet
legte russland beide abstimmung ein veto
ein china indien und die vereinigten
arabischen emirate enthielten sich die
restlichen elf staaten stimmten für den
text
die nato verstärkt ihre ostflanke weiter
und schickt teile der schnellen
eingreiftruppe in die dortigen
mitgliedsländer deutschland will eine
kompanie in die slowakei verlegen
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg sagte
man werde alles tun um jeden verbündeten
und jeden zentimeter nato gebiet zu
verteidigen
deutschland ist mit rund 14.000
soldatinnen und soldaten an der
schnellen eingreiftruppe beteiligt der
vorsitzende des deutschen
bundesverbandes wüstner äußerte sich
dazu im zdf morgenmagazin
es geht darum die partner an der
ostflanke zu unterstützen zu stärken es
geht um brasilien zur
widerstandsfähigkeit für das was wir
angebot haben in der nato dafür stehen
wir bereit politik muss jetzt aber
endlich aufwachen bezogen auf die
strategischen herausforderung mit blick
auf putin aber auch mit blick auf die
äußere sicherheit und auch die
bundeswehr endlich stärken für ihren
auftrag ausstatten das ist auch das
gebot der stunde
unterdessen verhandeln moskau und kiew
über direkte gespräche dabei geht es vor
allem um den ort des treffens russland
hatte die belarussische hauptstadt minsk
vorgeschlagen was die ukrainische
regierung ablehnt nun hat sich ungarn
als gastgeber angeboten in die orients
hauptstadt tiflis haben am abend
zehntausende gegen den russischen
einmarsch in die ukraine protestiert sie
forderten den rücktritt von premier
caritas willi dessen regierung hatte
sich den sanktionen gegen russland nicht
angeschlossen
immerhin gibt es beim wetter lichtblicke
benjamin stöver hat die durchaus
passablen aussichten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielen dank server und guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen zum moma wetter am
samstag wir beginnen mit einem blick auf
die europa temperaturen karte und sehen
bei uns in mitteleuropa werte um die
fünf grad es ist die kühle luft des
nordens die in unsere richtung fließt so
richtig winterlich ist das nicht immer
noch viel zu mild für die jahreszeit
aber eben doch noch mal auffällig weil
auch zum beginn der kommenden woche es
deutlich milder werden wird im moment
kriegen wir aber auf der ostseite dieses
hochdruckgebiet eben die kühle luft aus
dem norden ab alles in allem sorgt
dieses hochdruckgebiet aber für
wetterberuhigung ruhig sonnig und
trocken das sind knapp zusammengefasst
die aussichten für die kommenden tag und
rund in diesem samstag starten wir heute
morgen mit schneeregen an den alpen und
auch im stau des erzgebirges das
verklingt über den vormittag ansonsten
weitgehend trocken allerdings im westen
der nebel im osten der hochnebel heute
morgen zum start in den tag bei
temperaturen teilweise deutlich unter
null grad vor allem in der südhälfte
minus vier grad meldet muss im
südschwarzwald fünf grad plus sind es
auf norderney und da wo wir uns bei um
die null grad bewegen kann es heute
morgen natürlich auch glatt seien auf
den strassen also vorsicht wenn sie sich
auf den weg machen der vormittag im
überblick viele sonnige momente gibt es
schon im nordwesten ansonsten von westen
lockert es mehr und mehr auf die schauer
im osten und im süden verklingen die
wolken sind allerdings noch nicht zum
nachmittag wird sich das auch dort mehr
lösen dann hat die sonne mehr chancen
sich blicken zu lassen das ganze bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen zwischen 2 grad
richtung alpenrand bis 10 grad
verbreitet im nordwesten und die
aussichten für die kommenden drei tage
die sind dann hochdruck geprägt morgen
ist es anfangs eben nordosten noch
neblig dicht aber im tagesverlauf wird
sich dass mehr und mehr lösen sehr viel
sonnenschein dann auch am montag nach
nebelauflösung vier bis elf grad und zum
dienstag noch milder sechs bis zwölf
grad allerdings im tagesverlauf von
nordwesten dichte wolken und schauer die
ins land ziehen soweit zum wetter für
den moment kommen sie mit diesen
aussichten jetzt gut in den samstag
[Musik]
guten tag um kurz nach acht herzlich
willkommen zu dieser sonderausgabe hier
morgenmagazin noch bis 10 uhr 30 live im
russischen angriffskrieg konzentrieren
sich die kämpfe gerade auf die
hauptstadt kiew auch in dieser nacht
nämlich schüsse und kämpfe am stadtrand
und präsident seelands geriet die
bewohner auf die stadt zu verteidigen ja
offenbar sind die führungen in kiew und
moskau gerade in kontakt über gespräche
russlands präsident putin hat diese
lenski ein gespräch in weißrussland
angeboten allerdings nicht er persönlich
sondern eine russische delegation und
die außenministerin berbalk hat das als
vergiftetes gesprächsangebot bezeichnet
es sind quasi verhandlungen über
verhandlungen denn putin stellt
bestimmte bedingungen die aktuelle lage
in der ukraine fast tim kröger jetzt
zusammen
über menschenleeren straßen ist ein
neuer morgen angebrochen noch ist kiew
nicht gefallen doch schüssel
durchbrechen die stille auch in der
nacht schon explosionen immer näher am
zentrum der unabhängigkeitsplatz wie
lange kann er noch verteidigt werden am
abend hatte der ukrainische präsident
seine bürger auf entscheidende stunden
vorbereitet wir dürfen unsere hauptstadt
nicht verlieren appellierte er obwohl er
selbst um sein leben fürchten muss und
macht jetzt hoffnung mit einer neuen
botschaft aus der dämmerung wir werden
die waffen nicht niederlegen wir werden
unseren staat verteidigen sagt er
hilft das hauptziel der russischen
invasion die russischen einheiten rücken
vor allem von norden an die stadt heran
der kreml wolle die ukrainische führung
ablösen und einer marionettenregierung
installieren so die lesart vieler
beobachter am späten abend schildert ein
notfallmediziner aus kiew im zdf die
situation können sie uns sagen wie viele
opfer des krieges sie jetzt bereits
behandeln mussten in der staat erhört
man dass es geschossen wird und
man hört auch explosionen
weil wir haben einen improvisierten
bunker leider müssen die bettlägerigen
patienten in den zimmern bleiben
und wir bieten immer an den gott dass er
kein geschoss zu uns kommt ein winziger
hoffnungsschimmer vielleicht laut
facebook seite eines sprechers der
ukrainischen führung werde gerade mit
den russen über mögliche verhandlungen
verhandelt ausgang mehr als ungewiss
noch aber es dass die realität russische
truppen greifen die ukraine von mehreren
seiten an inaktiv etwa stellen sich
ihnen ukrainische soldaten entgegen
detonationen in der nähe angst auf den
straßen
dieser vater zeigt wie der vorhang seine
tochter vor den zersplitternden fenstern
bewahrt habe
sie mussten in der u-bahn-station
schlafen es war sehr voll menschen saßen
auf stühlen wir blieben an einem platz
weil dort ein süßer hund war den mochte
ich sehr
fahrradhelme gegen bomben u bahnhöfe und
heizungskeller werden zu schutzräumen
zig-tausende sehen nur noch die flucht
als ausweg die bittere realität des
krieges
noch ist kiew nicht gefallen das bangen
geht weiter
annafest uns noch einmal aus moskau
zugeschaltet die deutsche
außenministerin annalena baerbock hatte
ja betont wir alle seien von putin
angelogen worden jetzt hören wir der
kreml ist zu verhandlungen bereit wie
ernst zu nehmen ist das
ja dieses gesprächsangebot dieses
angebot zu friedensverhandlungen gibt es
ja seit dem ersten kriegstag also seit
donnerstag da haben die mittagszeit
hatte sich der belarussische präsident
lukaschenko geäußert und gemeldet und
sagte er habe eben mit putin gesprochen
putin sei gesprächsbereit mit der
ukraine dieser krieg sei zu stoppen
putin hatte zwei bedingungen einmal die
ukraine rückt ab von einer nato
mitgliedschaft und die ukraine wird
komplett entmilitarisiert ort dieser
friedensverhandlungen könnte
entsprechend minsk sein dieses
gesprächsangebot wurde dann über die tat
und über die stunden immer wieder
aufrecht erhalten und immer wieder
wiederholt von unterschiedlichen
ministern von unterschiedlichen
russischen sprecher und nun meldete sich
gestern selensky bat um ein gespräch und
daraufhin so heißt es also so das
russische mehr aktiv hätte putin sofort
zum telefonhörer gegriffen und hätte
sofort lukaschenko angerufen und eben
klar gemacht dass diese gespräche in
minsk stattfinden können aber sie lenski
hätte das dann nicht gewollt der hätte
dann lieber warschau gewollt und sei
dann nicht mehr ans telefon gegangen
insofern ist das also das ist das
russische narrativ was verbreitet wird
aber eben kein offenes gesprächsangebot
weil es eben an bedingungen geknüpft ist
können sie uns die stimmung in der
russischen bevölkerung schildern es gibt
ja davon haben wir auch schon bilder
gesehen durchaus einige menschen die
ganz offen protestieren
die proteste sind sehr klein also wir
hatten am ersten abend am
donnerstagabend etwas größere proteste
hiermit
1797 festnahmen waren es glaube ich wir
hatten gestern abend hier in der
hauptstadt moskau auch wieder ein
protest aber es war
verhältnismäßig also die demonstranten
ließen sich an zwei händen abzählen
es war viel presse da und viel polizei
ist kam landesweit wieder zu ich glaube
über 500 festnahmen daran lässt sich
einerseits so ein bisschen ablesen
dass natürlich anti kriegs stimmen gibt
eine straßenumfrage von uns hatte
gezeigt dass es natürlich nicht
repräsentativ aber hat er gezeigt dass
insbesondere die jüngere bevölkerung
sehr skeptisch dem krieg gegenüber
eingestellt ist während die ältere
bevölkerung eher dem narrativ von putin
für diesen krieg folgt nämlich das
besagt ja die ukraine gehört zu russland
und russland gehöre sich jetzt hole sich
jetzt das zurück was zu ihm gehört die
einordnung von anna 5 aus moskau für den
augenblick dankeschön
wenn dieser angriff eines gezeigt hat
dann dass man mit allem rechnen muss und
beziehungsweise das eben russlands
präsident putin unberechenbar ist und
entsprechend große sorgen haben auch die
nachbarstaaten und dazu gehört eben auch
lettland und wir sind jetzt verbunden
mit dem präsidenten lettlands mit egs
lewitz guten morgen herr präsident
mutmaßlich sind sie in riga einen
schönen guten tag
guten tag herr präsident es hat zuletzt
deutliche signale der nato partner
gegeben die ostflanke zu schützen sind
sie zufrieden mit dem was jetzt gerade
passiert also mit den zusagen der
bündnispartner meine ich natürlich
konkret
gestern war ich auf der
außerordentlichen sitzung des nato rates
und alle 30 mitgliedsstaaten der nato
waren sich einig dass die ostflanke der
nato gestärkt werden muss zugleich fand
auch eine sitzung des formats des
sogenannten bukarest vokalisten formats
neun
mitgliedsstaaten der nato in zentrale
machbar zusammengeschlossen sind und wir
alle
beschlossen dass die ostflanke gestärkt
werden muss
das wird schon zum teil getan und gerade
jetzt werden neue maßnahmen getroffen
also die stärkung des personals militär
personals und die stärkung der
ausrüstung die vereinigten staaten haben
mehrere tausend soldaten in die region
verlegt auch die vereinigte vereinigte
königreich in estland kanada will die
truppen in lettland verstärken
deutschland dafür danke ich besonders
deutschland will die truppen in litauen
verstärken und jetzt wird eine neue
einheit in den
merker staaten in rumänien unter der
französischen
organisiert herr präsident irland hat
eine gut 290 kilometer lange außen
grenze zu russland irland grenzt
außerdem auch an weißrussland
vielleicht können sie uns schildern was
hat sich in den letzten tagen in ihrem
land verändert wir
haben die grenzbefestigungen nochmals
gestärkt aber die situation an der
grenze ist ruhig jeder vierte lette jede
vierte latin spricht russisch wie ist
die stimmung in ihrer bevölkerung
hinsichtlich der russischen offensive
jetzt in der ukraine wie können wir uns
das vorstellen
also wir zeigen eine sehr große
einigkeit in der gesellschaft wir stehen
an der seite der ukraine es gibt eine
kleine minderheit
sagen wir migranten aus der früheren
sowjetunion ältere leute meistens die
noch in dem sog der russischen
propaganda erleben aber wir sind nicht
relevant aus die große mehrheit also ich
würde sagen fast geschlossenen der
lettischen gesellschaft
steht so nato europäischen union und zur
ukraine in diesem angriffskrieg dass
russland wegen der ihn entführt sie
haben sicher präsident ganz klar für
weitgehende strafmaßnahmen gegen
russland ausgesprochen jetzt gibt es
sanktionen die auf den weg gebracht
worden sind von seiten der europäischen
union aber auch usa hat scharfe
sanktionen verhängt an welche genau
denken sie kann man noch mehr
strafmaßnahmen auf den weg bringen als
jetzt schon geschehen
gestern hat die europäischen union sehr
weitreichende sanktionen gegen russland
es geht um abschneiden des von russland
von den finanzmärkten von anderen
maßnahmen auch individuelle maßnahmen
putin selbst um gegen seinen
außenminister lavrov der ja seine sein
vermögen dann im ausland gehortet hat
also das wird jetzt riskiert
so dass die maßnahmen sehr weitreichend
sind aber es gibt noch potenzial weitere
maßnahmen gestern habe ich auch der
sitzung des nato-rates
verlangt dass auch russland auch vom
sieg
getrennt wird da auch andere staatschefs
haben das
unterstützt ich glaube die diskussion
geht weiter wir kommen auch zur
abschaltung von stift für russland was
natürlich noch
besondere besonderen einschnitt für die
russische kolonie bedeuten wird wir
haben gesprochen mit lettlands
präsidenten egles lewitz der
hervorragend deutsch spricht wie sie
jetzt gerade gehört haben wir bedanken
uns für das interview wünschen ihnen
alles gute vielen dank
aber es wurde dankeschön
dieser russische angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine hat uns alle und die politik ja
wirklich brutal aufgerüttelt wir müssen
auf einmal registrieren dass frieden in
europa kein automatismus kein
dauerhafter begleiter mehr ist ebenso
der staat der den schutz seiner
bürgerinnen und bürger ja garantieren
soll ist aber im absoluten ernstfall
wohl nicht könnte ja das zumindest haben
auch diverse hochrangige militärs hier
in deutschland gesagt was das für die
bündnisse und landesverteidigung
bedeutet das heute morgen auch schon von
andré wüstner gehört aus der politik
sind jedenfalls deutliche signale zu
vernehmen dass sich das so schnell wie
möglich ändern soll damit uns in unseren
partnern ein schicksal wie den ukrainern
niemals passieren kann jan fritsche dazu
gestern abend wieder ukrainische flaggen
vor dem kanzleramt unter den
demonstranten soja sah ihn ihre
schwester mit zwei kindern hat es raus
aus der ukraine geschafft ist über
rumänien auf dem weg nach deutschland
doch die sorge um verwandte und freunde
bleibt riesig
ich bin 44 jahre alt aber ich habe mich
so schlimm noch nicht wirklich gefüllt
ich seit zwei tage ich kann nicht
schlafen ich habe kopfschmerzen
ich zittere in mir drin
tausende flüchtlinge wie hier in polen
sind schon unterwegs die vereinten
nationen stellen sich auf bis zu vier
millionen ein die bundes innenministerin
wirbt für die aufnahme von flüchtlingen
anders als beim syrien krieg soll
diesmal ein vorteil mechanismus her am
sonntag beraten dazu die eu
innenminister es wäre gut wenn wir dort
auch ein unbürokratisches verfahren auf
der eu ebene miteinander vereinbaren
hier erscheint mir ein gemeinsames
vorgehen sehr
zielführend aus dem kreml kam das dann
überraschend ein angebot für mögliche
friedensverhandlungen allerdings zu kaum
annehmbaren bedingungen für die bundes
außenministerin ein vergiftetes angebot
in einem moment wo russland ein land
bombardiert unschuldige menschen
bombardiert da ist wohl nicht der moment
gekommen wo man sagt das ist ein
ernsthaft gemeintes angebot und wir
haben in den letzten wochen gesehen dass
nichts ernsthaft gemeint war stattdessen
will deutschland seine militärische
präsenz an der natur ostflanke weiter
ausbauen wir werden uns in der slowakei
engagieren dort eine kompanie in jetzt
auch zügig in gang setzen aufwachsen
soll das ganze zu einer battle group und
auch bei der luftverteidigung werden wir
uns einander scherben dabei ist zuletzt
die frage wieder lauter geworden die
verteidigungsfähigkeit die bundeswehr
überhaupt und wie viel ist sie uns wert
wir müssen als bundesrepublik
deutschland prioritäten setzen eine
eigene strategie entwickeln und da hat
der prioritäten und vorhänge dann
tatsächlich auch die bundeswehr
einsatzfähiger machen entscheidend ist
dass der politische wille da ist die
bundeswehr besser aufzustellen und da
gibt es verbesserungsbedarf so viel ist
sicher der krieg in der ukraine stellt
auch die deutsche politik vor viele
fragen
und jetzt begrüße ich in münchen stefan
meyer der gerade gestern zum csu
generalsekretär gewählt worden ist guten
tag herr meier guten morgen treffen
wollen fühlt der politische
aschermittwoch ist abgesagt wir werden
bei ihnen die ereignisse in der ukraine
besprochen
natürlich sind alle auch gerade in
bayern schockiert es gibt ja
beispielsweise eine städtepartnerschaft
zwischen der landeshauptstadt münchen
und kiew aber auch weit über münchen
hinaus ist die betroffenheit enorm
unsere unsere gedanken unser mitgefühl
ich sage aber auch ganz deutlich auch
unsere gebete sind bei den bürgerinnen
und bürger in der ukraine insbesondere
in der hauptstadt in kiew die ja gerade
zur stunde massiv unter bombardements
steht aber auch gerade in der ost
ukraine wo die kämpfe auch sehr stark
von statten gehen wir sind hier
natürlich genauso betroffen wie gesamt
deutschland wie bewerten sie das
vorgehen das verhalten der
bundesregierung aktuell
wir unterstützen die bundesregierung
gerade in dieser extremen krisenhaften
situation geschickt würde sich nicht
gezwungen wenn die größte
oppositionsfraktion insbesondere auch
die csu hier nichts solidarität an den
tag legen würden und ich bin auch der
überzeugung dass die bundesregierung
bislang auch in dieser krisenhaften
situation richtig gehandelt hat
gerade die demokratischen parteien in
deutschland sollten in dieser jedoch
massiven
krise weltpolitischen krise auch jetzt
zusammenstehen ihre partei hat in den
vergangenen jahren die politik der
bundesregierung mitgetragen und
mitbestimmt auch wenn sie jetzt in der
opposition sind was ist hier auf
politischer ebene versäumt worden es gab
ja selbstkritische töne von naivität
gegenüber russland auch versäumnisse bei
der ausstattung der bundeswehr
beispielsweise
auf dem feld ich möchte schon deutlich
machen die csu ist die partei der
bundeswehr und wir haben gerade auch in
den letzten jahren massiv dafür geworben
den verteidigungshaushalt zu erhöhen
dass dies ist uns auch teilweise
gelungen nicht vollends das möchte ich
durchaus zugestehen
aber in einer regierung ist man
natürlich immer auch vom
koalitionspartner mit abhängig aber
jetzt gilt es nach vorn zu schauen und
wir müssen die bundeswehr deutlich
sachgerechte und besser ausstatten es
geht nicht um eine aufrüstung weil das
teilweise auch aus meiner sicht falsch
apostrophiert wird sondern es geht um
eine sachgerechte um eine angemessene
ausstattung der bundeswehr und ich bin
sehr froh dass die neue bundesregierung
erkannt hat dass der zunächst
eingeschlagene kurs die mittel im
verteidigungshaushalt zu kürzen falsch
ist zumindest große teile der ampel
regierung sprechen sie für einen
notwendigen aufwuchs des
verteidigungsetats aus hier hat die
ampel regierung auch klar die
unterstützung der csu aber es ist schon
ein bisschen wenn dann beispielsweise
der
spd-fraktionsvorsitzende mützenich auch
diesen aufwuchs des verteidigungsetats
durchaus wieder infrage stellt herr
meier sie sagen die csu sei die partei
der bundeswehr wir wissen vor allem
jahren wurde die wehrpflicht ausgesetzt
bedeutet dass ihrer meinung nach die
soll wieder eingeführt werden
ich glaube dass man sich jetzt mit den
aktuellen herausforderungen
beschäftigen muss und die große aktuelle
herausforderung ist mit verlaub nicht
die frage ob die aussetzung der
wehrpflicht wieder revidiert werden
sollte sondern jetzt geht es darum die
bundeswehr die aktuelle bundeswehr
unsere bundeswehr soldatinnen und
soldaten die wir gerade eben auch wieder
gehört haben in sehr großer zahl auch
beispielsweise in litauen im einsatz
sind auch angemessen auszustatten und
wenn uns dann meldungen erreichen dass
elementare dinge wie beispielsweise
ausreichende unterwäsche oder oder auch
winterfeste unterwäsche dort nicht
vorhanden ist dann muss dies wirklich
ein alarmsignal für die deutsche politik
sein hier muss deutlich schneller als in
der vergangenheit auch eine sachgerechte
ausstattung der bundeswehr erreicht
werden und ich meine da auch
beispielsweise ganz deutlich das
erreichen des zwei prozent ziel wir als
csu haben uns immer klar dafür
ausgesprochen dass wir unseren
bündnisverpflichtungen in der nato auch
entsprechend nachkommen sollten was das
zwei prozent ziel anbelangt leider ist
dies auch in der vergangenheit an
unserem damaligen koalitionspartner
gescheitert jetzt gilt es hier wirklich
schnellstmöglich und ich sage auch ganz
deutlich die bündnis und die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der bundeswehr zu
verbessern und ganz konkret dass zwei
prozent ziel auch möglichst bis 2023
dann auch anzustreben es geht aber nicht
nur um eine bessere ausstattung der
bundeswehr schon es geht insgesamt auch
um eine bessere ausstattung des
bevölkerungsschutzes in deutschland also
auch des zivilen bevölkerungsschutzes
auch hier sollte die neue
bundesregierung deutlich stärkere
anstrengungen unternehmen stephan mayer
der neue generalsekretär der csu war das
dankeschön für dieses gespräch
tag drei des krieges des russischen
angriff auf die ukraine augenblicklich
gibt es diverse explosionen in der
hauptstadt kiew der ukrainische
präsident hat ein angebot der usa
abgelehnt aus kiew sozusagen
herauszugehen zu kommen mit hilfe der
usa und sagt selber wir werden die
waffen nicht niederlegen wir werden
unseren staat verteidigen das hat
natürlich politische ja schockwellen
ausgelöst wir wollen jetzt sprechen mit
unserem korrespondenten unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten karl
hinterleitner
wie soll deutschland auf die krise
reagieren karl es gibt ja wirklich
deutliche erschütterungen was die
ausrichtungen der außen der
sicherheitspolitik angeht nehmen wir mal
das thema waffenlieferungen das wurde
lange lange abgelehnt waffenlieferungen
die ukraine wird das so bleiben weil es
gibt auch in der regierungspartei
teilweise unterschiedliche
natürlich hat das alles hier eine
zeitenwende ausgelöst ein völliges
umdenken eine neubewertung dafür der
vielleicht die vielleicht klarste
aussage dass auf den punkt bringt war
von robert habeck dem
wirtschaftsminister dem grünen
wirtschaftsminister sagt wir waren in
der vergangenheit zu naiv haben die lage
falsch eingeschätzt und müssen uns jetzt
neu justieren und das gilt natürlich für
das gesamte politische berlin wie auch
für die regierung aber auch für
außenpolitiker profilierte
außenpolitiker aus anderen parteien
du hast vorhin erwähnt die
waffenlieferungen die mehr
ausgeschlossen worden sind norbert
röttgen ist einer derjenigen die das
getan hat der probiert ist
außenpolitiker der union der seine
meinung jetzt geändert hat hat der
gesagt hat wir haben immer auf dialog
gesetzt waffen kam nicht in frage die
dialog der sieht man der ist so klar
gescheitert dass wir auch das jetzt in
erwägung ziehen müssen das also nur ein
beispiel ein anderes kam im gespräch
vorhin mit dem cd csu-generalsekretär
meyer vor das ist natürlich die
ausstattung der bundeswehr
hier gibt es auch eine klare
positionierung christian lindner der
finanzminister sagt wir haben die
friedensdividende in den 90ern falsch
eingeschätzt oder haben uns zu lange
darauf verlassen sagten wir brauchen
verteidigung nicht mehr das noch ein
anderer zum beispiel die usa und dann
haben wir die landesverteidigung über
die jahre vernachlässigt das muss jetzt
anders werden da muss mehr geld rein
fließen auch der generalsekretär
bijan djir sarai von der fdp sagt das
selbst bei den grünen gibt es da
vorsichtige zustimmung und wir haben
zeugen gehört aber auch schon gewisse
auseinandersetzung innerhalb der
koalition die sich der andeuten der
spd-generalsekretär
fraktionsvorsitzende rolf mützenich hat
schon dem widersprochen also das ist ein
thema die dass das uns noch begleiten
wird für waffenlieferungen ukraine wäre
es ohnehin zu spät und eine aufrüstung
oder eine aufstockung der bundeswehr
würde lange dauern aber das thema ist
auf dem tisch das alles wird diskutiert
und es wird diese andere regierung noch
beschäftigen karl letzte frage putin
machte also oder hat ernst gemacht und
wie viele andere scheint eben auch die
politik kalt erwischt worden zu sein der
westen hat sanktionen jetzt auf den weg
gebracht will sie schnell umsetzen was
jetzt kontrovers diskutiert wird ist das
thema swift dieses internationale
transaktions system russland soll dort
ausgeschlossen werden um es dem land
eben schwerer zu machen darum die frage
der bundeskanzler so heißt es hält das
noch zurück obwohl die anderen länder
druck machen das hat im grunde gerade
auch der lettische präsident bei uns im
interview bestätigt gibt es da noch ein
umdenken vom kanzler in den nächsten
tagen
das wird man sehen müssen also die große
frage ist ja die die der bundespräsident
gestern aufgeworfen hat er sagte dieses
unrecht kann ich ohne antwort bleiben
die frage ist wie sieht diese antwort
aus und nehmen die interaktionen die
jetzt beschlossen worden sind ist
natürlich trifft eine ganz scharfe waffe
aber da gibt es noch unstimmigkeiten
nicht zuletzt weil so ein ausstieg aus
dem zahlungssystem natürlich auch die
partner- und damit die eigenen firmen
deutsche filme europäische filme werden
betreffen würde das muss also wohl
abgewogen werden und diese
abwägungsprozess der ist zurzeit noch im
gang danke für die einschätzung karl
hinterleitner war das unser hauptstadt
kostet empfehlen kann
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio variiert von waldenfels
und mitri sirin
willkommen an diesem samstag ein
außerplanmäßiges zdf morgenmagazin noch
bis 10 uhr 30 und wir wollen diese halbe
stunde beginnen mit neuen bildern aus
kiew aus der ukrainischen hauptstadt vor
wenigen minuten wurde dort ein gebäude
mitten im zentrum beschädigt womit genau
dazu gibt es noch keine informationen
auch über die opfer wissen wir noch
nichts diese videos werden aktuell auf
twitter von den einwohnern kiews geteilt
man sieht die rauchschwaden sind mehrere
kilometer weit zu sehen ja es gibt viele
dieser videos die aktuell im netz
kursieren es gibt feuer in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt hier ist dass
die gegend um den zoo von kiew auch
geteilt von bewohnern dort in kerth die
über twitter und andere soziale
netzwerke eben hin und das muss man
tragischerweise sagen live in unsere
wohnzimmer kommen von einem krieg in
europa ist wirklich krass wir werden das
ganze hier im morgenmagazin über ein
orte natürlich mit unseren
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
haben aber auch und werden weiter
politische gespräche führen unter
anderem haben wir gesprochen mit sergey
lagodinsky den russland politischen
sprecher der grünen fraktion im
eu-parlament wir haben vor wenigen
augenblicken gesprochen mit dem neuen
csu generalsekretär stephan mayer unter
anderem über den zustand der bundeswehr
und wir haben noch ein gespräch geplant
mit oliver müller von der caritas
international über kurzfristige
humanitäre hilfe für die menschen in der
ukraine und wie es den menschen dort
geht und hatten spontaner weise ein
gespräch gehabt noch mit lettlands
präsident der sich bei deutschland
bedankt für die unterstützung der nato
ostflanke wir machen weiter mit
nachrichten heute express kurz und
kompakt jetzt keine silbe richter hallo
nochmals guten morgen hallo nach berlin
und guten morgen liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer von uns jetzt sehr kurze
überblick und da schauen wir zunächst
auf die situation in der ukraine wo auch
rund um die hauptstadt kiew gekämpft
wird nach behördenangaben gibt es in
mehreren stadtteilen straßenkämpfe mit
russischen die bevölkerung soll
schutzräume aufsuchen und dort bleiben
präsident seelands gemeldete sich am
morgen erneut mit einer video botschaft
darin forderte er die menschen zum
durchhalten auf er selbst werde auf
jeden fall in kiew bleiben
im un-sicherheitsrat ist eine resolution
gescheitert die den angriff auf die
ukraine verurteilen sollte wie erwartet
legte russland bei der abstimmung ein
veto ein china indien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate
enthielten sich die restlichen elf
staaten stimmten für den text
die nato verstärkt ihre ostflanke weiter
und schickt teile der schnellen
eingreiftruppe in die dortigen
mitgliedsländer deutschland will eine
kompanie in die slowakei verlegen
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg sagte
man werde alles tun um jeden verbündeten
und jeden zentimeter nato gebiet zu
verteidigen
unterdessen verhandeln moskau und kiew
über direkte gespräche dabei geht es vor
allem um den ort des treffens russland
hatte die belarussische hauptstadt minsk
vorgeschlagen was die ukrainische
regierung ablehnt nun hat sich ungarn
als gastgeber angeboten in georgiens
hauptstadt tiflis haben am abend
zehntausende gegen den russischen
einmarsch in die ukraine protestiert und
30.000 menschen schwenkten ukrainische
und georgische flaggen und sangen die
nationalhymne der beiden länder
georgiens bestreben nato mitglied zu
werden sorgt wie bei der ukraine seit
jahren für konflikte mit russland
schauen wir noch kurz aufs thema corona
denn heute starten die ersten nowaks
impfungen und zwar in hamburg
schleswig-holstein und dem saarland das
wachsen soll vorrangig beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen angeboten werden denn
dort gilt ab mitte märz eine einrichtung
bezogene impfpflicht als sogenannter
proteine im stoff bietet nowaks
denjenigen eine alternative die der m
rna technologie skeptisch
gegenüberstehen
das wetter zeigt sich halbwegs wochenend
tauglich und benjamin stöbe sagt ihnen
was das heißt
[Musik]
ja das tut es vielen dank server und
guten morgen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer herzlich willkommen zum
wochenend tauglichen mona wetter am
samstag sie sehen das große
hochdruckgebiet auf unserer iso barren
karte das hält die tiefdruckgebiete und
deren einfluss auf abstand sorgt aber
gleichzeitig dafür dass auf der ostseite
dieses hochs eben doch noch mal sehr
kühle luft aus dem hohen norden in
unsere richtung strebt das bedeutet
temperaturen heute morgen durchaus
deutlich unter null minus vier grad
meldet stühlingen an der grenze zur
schweiz fünf grad plus sind es auf
norderney da wo wir uns bei um die null
grad befinden kann es nach feuchter
nacht durchaus heute morgen auch noch
glatt sein außerdem ist nebel im westen
ein thema hochnebel liegt im osten da
sehen wir auch beim blick auf die karte
für den vormittag gleichzeitig
verklingen im stau der berge richtung
erzgebirge und alpen letzte
schneeschauer der nacht im westen vor
allem im nordwesten lässt sich schon
intensiv die sonne blicken die wird sich
im tagesverlauf mehr und mehr
durchsetzen können vor allem auch im
südwesten aber auch im osten werden die
lücken in der wolken und nebel decke
größer dann haben wir den
hochdruckeinfluss voll am wirken bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute zwischen
zwei grad richtung alpenrand bis 10 grad
verbreitet im nordwesten jetzt der blick
auf die aussichten für die kommenden
drei tage morgen nach nebelauflösung
durchaus freundlich vier bis elf grad
die temperaturen auch milder wird es von
tag zu tag am montag gleiches spiel sehr
viel sonnenschein für alle ab dienstag
dann allerdings von nordwesten im
tagesverlauf dichtere wolken und schauer
aber auch der dienstag sehr mild sechs
bis zwölf grad die
tageshöchsttemperaturen soweit zum
wetter für den moment kommen sie mit
diesen aussichten jetzt gut in den
samstag
[Musik]
kurz nach halb neun an diesem samstag
die wir zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
ganz herzlich willkommen zu einer
sonderausgabe des morgenmagazins
außerplanmäßig heute auch am samstag
aufgrund der aktuellen nachrichtenlage
tag 3 der russischen invasion in die
ukraine die kämpfe halten natürlich
unvermindert an soeben wird gemeldet
dass
das russische militär zumindest nach
eigenen angaben die stadt milito pohl im
südosten der ukraine eingenommen hat es
ist natürlich alles wahnsinnig schwer zu
verifizieren es ist eben eine
propagandaschlacht aber wir versuchen
jetzt mal herauszufinden mit katrin
eigendorf die in der ukraine ist was
sich dort abspielt südwestlich von der
ukrainischen hauptstadt einen guten
morgen und kathrin was können sie uns
berichten
ja wir sind hier in wie nizza 200
kilometer von kiew entfernt und auch
hier hat es in der nacht luftalarm
gegeben 30 kilometer von hier entfernt
hat die ukrainische armee nach eigenen
angaben einen russischen kampfjet
abgeschossen das ist nicht der einzige
nach regierungsangaben der getroffen
wurde es sind wohl mehrere kampfjets der
russen abgeschossen worden aber
natürlich ist die situation vor allem in
kiew wichtig wo russland jetzt im
prinzip bestrebt ist diese stadt mit
bodentruppen zu erobern wie sich die
lage darstellt scheint die ukrainische
armee doch weitaus mehr widerstand
leisten zu können und weitaus besser
diesen kampf gewachsen zu sein als putin
das wohl angenommen hatte es ist so dass
die das dass die russen jetzt hier in
kiew das hören wir aus unterschiedlichen
quellen tschetschenische sonderkommandos
einsetzen will und auch schon im einsatz
hat das muss man sich vorstellen sind
eine art söldnertruppen die hier im
auftrag russlands unterwegs sind weil
wohl die russische armee dem alleine
nicht wirklich gewachsen zu sein scheint
hier mit bodentruppen einen kampf um die
hauptstadt zu führen wir müssen uns
einfach darauf einrichten dass in kiew
ist wirklich zu harten
auseinandersetzungen und kämpfen kommen
wird zwischen der russischen armee
russischen bodentruppen
der ukrainischen armee aber auch
zivilisten die ja mittlerweile
breitflächig mit waffen ausgestattet
wurden also man muss wirklich damit
rechnen damit müssen die russen auch
rechnen dass die zivilbevölkerung hier
auch ganz extremen widerstand leisten
wird also ein langwieriger häuserkampf
der dazu erwarten ist natürlich ist die
hauptstadt kiew ein sehr sehr wichtiges
zu verteidigen das ziel für die ukraine
aber man hört ja auch aus anderen teilen
des landes dass das militär dort
vordringt jetzt zumindest nach
russischen angaben im südosten milito
pohl kriegen sie davon irgendetwas mit
was im rest des landes passiert
ja wir bekommen hier natürlich auch
permanent informationen vor allem von
von den ukrainischen militärs von der
ukrainischen regierung wir können das
vor ort nicht jeweils verifizieren aber
die russen drängen sicherlich in vielen
teilen des landes jetzt vor also ein
hauptmerkmal hauptaugenmerk der russen
liegt natürlich auch darüber darin die
hafenstadt im osten mario pohl ein
wichtiges industriezentrum und
verbindung zur krim zu
erobern es gibt wohl auch sehr schwere
kämpfe um die stadt charkiw auch im
osten der ukraine
aber wie gesagt das hauptaugenmerk liegt
im moment auf kiew denn die strategie
der russen ist ja nicht das land jetzt
hier komplett zu besatz zu besetzen
dafür haben sie gar nicht genug truppen
hier im einsatz sondern die strategie
ist relativ schnell die regierung
präsident seelands geht für entmachten
und eine russland freundliche
marionettenregierung hier zu
installieren und was ich beobachte und
was im prinzip auch ja sehr erstaunlich
ist wie sehr sich dieser präsident
selensky in der krise hier als guter
manager er weiß der wirklich das heft in
die hand nimmt und auf allen ebenen
versucht hier doch erfolge zu erzielen
in kooperation mit internationalen
partnern in appellen an die russische
bevölkerung
dar in der eigenen bevölkerung immer
wieder mut zu machen für widerstand zu
werben aber auch zu versuchen das
gespräch mit russlands präsident putin
zu suchen
also ich sehe sie lenski in diesem
moment hier wirklich als sehr sehr
kompetenten krisenmanager live aus dem
südwesten der ukraine unsere reporterin
und korrespondentin katrin eigendorf
dankeschön
die ukraine hat ungefähr halb so viele
einwohner wie wir also ca 40 millionen
und das heißt unzählige menschen die
richtung westen fliehen viele natürlich
erst einmal in die nachbarländer nach
polen ungarn rumänien
moldawien oder in die slowakei und wir
wollen jetzt zu einer korrespondentin
schalten und zwar an die grenze zu polen
zu natalie steger wo genau sind sie und
kommen dort viele menschen an
wir sind in churchill an der ukrainisch
polnischen grenze und hier ist gerade
ein zug aus kiew angekommen mit etwa
1000 menschen zu hören wir und so soll
es heute alle vier stunden weitergehen
das noch weiter züge aus kiew kommen die
züge waren gestern sehr sehr stark
verspäteter stand die sorge im raum das
vielleicht gar keine züge mehr
herauskommen aus der ukraine aber nun
funktioniert es eben dennoch an den auto
grenzübergängen stehen die autoschlange
mittlerweile
24 stunden in der schlange warten die
menschen warten sehr sehr lange auch
lange schlangen um die ukraine zu
verlassen und das ganze bei minus drei
grad
was brauchen die menschen jetzt ganz
akut wie kann man ihnen helfen
nun den menschen wird hier erst mal
erstversorgung geliefert medizinisch
psychologisch das militär die behörden
helfen mittlerweile gibt es gigantische
sachspenden die hier ankommen es wird
jetzt natürlich auch darum gehen die
leute hier im land zu verteilen sind
sehr viele ukrainer in polen alleine
schon seit 2014 seit der ersten vier
ersten flüchtlingswelle nach der krim
annexion also das wird sicherlich ganz
wichtig sein dass die menschheit zu
hause kommen weil sie im moment wirklich
nicht wissen ob und wann sie
zurückkommen und in der sekunde kurz
bevor mir sprechen hat mich eine e-mail
erreicht aus deutschland aus frankfurt
und hat mir jemand geschrieben ich
stelle wohnung für eine mutter mit
kindern aus lebus zur verfügung weil er
noch ein paar zimmer frei hat natalie
steger mit eindrücken und informationen
live von der ukrainischen grenze zu
polen und wir gehen weiter zur grenze
zur slowakei genau und da steht für uns
jetzt die kollegin britta hilpert einen
schönen guten morgen britta was kannst
du uns über die situation dort berichten
und wo bist du genau
also ich stehe hier in wien im jetzt
gehe auf der slowakischen seite von
oscar dort einer ukrainischen großstadt
und man sieht glaube ich hinter mir die
leute kommen jetzt in einem schnelleren
takt kann man sagen gestern kam sie
immer so schubweise auch jetzt ist es
immer noch schön das heißt nur 30 leute
kennen abgefertigt werden in einer
halben stunde war tatsächlich auf
ukrainischer seite genau kontrolliert
wird und auch die slowakische macht noch
zollkontrollen das erscheint mir
unglaublich es ist von wartezeiten die
rede von zwei bis zwölf stunden habe ich
schon alles gehört die leute kommen an
die grenze zu fuß mit autobussen mit dem
zug nach uster dort und dann weiter zu
fuß mit dem auto sie versuchen hier an
die grenze zu kommen und überall hier
stehen leute die helfen wollen teilweise
sind es verwandte genau wie bei natalie
in polen/ukraine die hier in tschechien
oder in der slowakei arbeiten jetzt ihre
verband ihre freunde abholen wollen oder
sind auch tschechen es in slowaken auch
deutsch habe ich hier schon getroffen
die einfach hergekommen sind und helfen
wollen also die menschen sind sehr
hilfsbereit die slowaken ist es die
slowakische regierung denn auch ist da
was vorbereitet schon
ja da ist was vorbereitet unweit von
hier gibt es eine zeltstadt die
aufgebaut wurde für die leute die nicht
hin wissen die nicht wissen wo sie hin
sollen aber mein eindruck hier ist dass
die hilfsbereitschaft vor ort so groß
ist und dass auch die verbindung in die
eu hinein von den ukrainern die hier
ankommen so groß ist dass die
größtenteils private unterkommen man
sieht auch wenn man hier über geht die
leute sitzen hier und warten einfach
abgeholt zu werden kontakt wird gehalten
über das mobiltelefon über das handy und
sie warten einfach darauf dass die leute
ihre freunde ihre familie sie abholen
die hier in tschechien in der slowakei
oder auch weiter weg in deutschland oder
italien wo britta es gibt irgendwie
schätzung vom
un-flüchtlingswerk dass innerhalb der
ukraine hunderttausende gerade flüchten
wir haben gestern schon gehört von
katrin eigendorf dass sie den eindruck
da sind natürlich sehr sehr viel mehr
gibt es da schon prognosen worauf stellt
sich die slowakei ein sind es tausende
oder sind es hunderttausende
also auf jeden fall werden dass tausende
sein das mit sicherheit es sind schon
tausende über die grenze gekommen jetzt
seit gestern ob hunderttausende wir
müssen abwarten ich kann mir ehrlich
gesagt nicht vorstellen dass sie das
weiter durchhalten hier die leute
wirklich durch zu kontrollieren wenn der
druck zu groß wird die autos auf der
anderen seite stellen sich auch selbst
die fußgänger die rüber kommen wollen
müssen mehrere stunden warten
der druck wird steigen das ist sicher
alle erzählen dass sie sehr lange
gebraucht haben um überhaupt bis zur
grenze zu kommen und dann dort noch
stunden warten müssten und das wird
wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer werden von
der slowakisch ukrainischen grenze war
dass britta hilpert live vielen vielen
dank und wir bleiben beim thema
flüchtlinge nämlich dieser krieg in fast
unzählige parallel stattfindende dramen
hunderttausende familien fliehen aus dem
land und vielfach komme frauen und
kinder ohne männer ohne väter in den
nachbarländern an weil sie an der grenze
eben von ihren familien getrennt worden
sind ja das sind teilweise wirklich
herzzerreißende szenen ganz ganz schlimm
hier ein vater der sich von seiner
tochter trennen muss weil er nicht
weiter darf weil er eben zu den männern
gehört die noch im kampf im wehrfähigen
alter sind und denen wurde und das das
land zu verlassen es ist abzusehen dass
die flugbewegungen in den nächsten tagen
massiv zunehmen wird und auch noch mehr
menschen zu uns nach deutschland kommen
über die aktuelle situation in bayern
und darüber hinaus jemand 20
wenn martha schmidt geht's nachrichten
von ihrer familie bekommt sind das
nachrichten aus dem krieg ihre mutter
lebt in der ukraine der vater die
geschwister und marta kann ihnen nicht
helfen hier von münchen aus
das ist einfach meine solidarität zu
zeigen
und umleitung nicht noch am wochenende
waren martas eltern zu besuch in münchen
seit gestern schicken sie handyvideos
wie dieses der flughafen der heimatstadt
ist offenbar bombardiert worden jetzt
ist die familie auf der flucht wer
reichen sie per video call in der nähe
der grenze zu ungarn letzte nacht haben
sie im auto verbracht
diese nacht brauchen wir unbedingt ein
bisschen schlaf aber es gibt keine
unterkunft nirgendwo hier alles hier ist
besetzt alles ist voll mit flüchtlingen
und verletzten besuchen weiter und
morgen versuchen wir wieder über die
grenze zu kommen
vor ein paar tagen habe ich mich noch
mit freunden getroffen und ich hatte
noch pläne wollte englisch lernen ein
normales leben führen sport machen und
jetzt sehe ich mich nach sicherheit und
möchte mit meinen beiden eltern zusammen
sein zusammen bleiben oder sich trennen
diese frage treibt gerade viele familien
in der ukraine um bei männer die in den
krieg ziehen könnten das land nicht mehr
verlassen dürfen keiner weiß wann man
sich wieder sieht
an den grenzen kilometerlange staus
tausende sind schon aus dem land
geflüchtet innerhalb der ukraine sollen
100.000 menschen auf der flucht sein im
ganzen land steigen sie entzüge
hauptsache weg von hier ziel und zukunft
ungewiss
wir wurden durch explosionen geweckt
dass es zu gefährlich es ist hier zu nah
an der frontlinie
wir wissen nicht wo wir am ende an
kommen die situation ändert sich so
schnell es ist schwer zu sagen wie die
uns führen
die eu hat mit einer östlichen
mitgliedstaaten notfallpläne erarbeitet
damit sofort menschen aufgenommen werden
können und auch die deutschen
bundesländer bereiten sich vor
zum einen wird es hilfe geben für die
unmittelbaren nachbarländer der ukraine
zum beispiel rumänien und anderen und
dann wenn wir selbst eigene kapazitäten
aufbauen aber über die größenordnung da
kann auch im moment nicht abschließend
entschieden werden aber wenn auf jeden
fall unseren beitrag leisten martha
schmidt hofft dass ihre familie geholfen
wird aber sie hat auch angst dass der
kontakt abbricht die handy akkus ihrer
eltern werden leerer und leerer und sie
finden im moment keinen ort wo sie ihre
telefone laden könnten
wie geht man mit krieg oben wie geht man
mit flucht um dramen und traumata wir
sprechen darüber jetzt mit dem
psychologen dr georg pieper angebot
morgen hallo
guten morgen
herr pieper hunderttausende sind gerade
auf der flucht viele von ihnen
sicherlich traumatisiert was macht so
eine flucht mit menschen
das sind erfahrungen die so einfach so
in das leben jetzt rein platzen die sich
diese menschen nicht vorgestellt hätten
also selbst die in der ukraine haben sie
ja doch eigentlich geglaubt dass das
nicht passieren könnte und das ist ja
das zeichen unserer zeit dass wir seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg in der westlichen
gesellschaft nicht mehr wirklich ein
krieg geglaubt haben das ist so weit weg
und plötzlich sind die menschen aus dem
alltag herausgerissen und mit diesen
grausamen dingen konfrontiert das ist
äußerst schwer zu verarbeiten wir senden
ja seit vorgestern und sehen sehr
eindringliche schlimme bilder von
menschen in u bahn tunnel von bomben von
frauen und kindern über die grenze kommt
gerade noch ein vater der sich von
seiner tochter hat verabschieden müssen
die bitterlich geweint was macht diese
situation mit den allerkleinsten
für die kinder ist das natürlich alles
sehr schwer nachvollziehbar sie
verstehen die hintergründe nicht und für
sie ist es nur ein ausgeprägtes gefühl
des vertrauensverlustes des sicherheits
verlustes und so etwas brennt sich in
die seele von kindern ein sie werden
damit mit sicherheit noch lange lange zu
tun haben und es wird viele folge
störungen geben das ist etwas was man ja
bei diesen
kriegsszenarien auch am anfang so leicht
vergisst das sind jahrelange folgen auf
der psychologischen ebene und die werden
immense slide hervorrufen herr pieper
vor allem die älteren menschen haben ja
als kinder den zweiten weltkrieg erlebt
was denken sie wie geht es diesen
menschen wenn sie jetzt wieder angst vor
bomben angst vor krieg haben müssen
auf diesen menschen
geht es im moment sehr sehr schlecht sie
haben auch nicht damit gerechnet und im
moment denke ich dass viele tatsächlich
damit konfrontiert sind dass sie angst
haben vor einem dritten weltkrieg
wir haben es hier mit einer person mit
herrn putin zu tun wo man sagen muss
dass er ein alter gekränkter
skrupelloser man mit einer ausgeprägten
narzisstischen persönlichkeitsstörung
dem alles zuzutrauen ist und gerade die
alten menschen wissen wie schlimm so
etwas war im zweiten weltkrieg
und sie fühlen sich sicherlich in einer
ähnlichen lage wie damals auch und
dadurch sind also tatsächlich starke
ängste und trauma symptome zur zeit für
viele aktuelle
gestern abend abendessen bei mir zu
hause und ich saß in meinem sohn
gegenüber und er hat mich gefragt was da
gerade passiert
und ich musste erst mal lange überlegen
was ich da eigentlich sage also wie
erkläre ich meinen kindern hier in
deutschland das krieg in europa ist
es ist wirklich ganz schwer das kindern
zu erklären wir müssen natürlich sehr
genau darauf schauen wie alt sind die
kinder eigentlich
und klar muss sein wir können die kinder
nicht davon fernhalten aber sobald sie
lesen können
lesen sie schlagzeilen oder bekommen
etwas im fernsehen mit
die
kleineren kinder noch die spüren die
anspannung der eltern und wir müssen als
eltern oder als bezugspersonen versuchen
ein gutes gleichgewicht hinzubekommen
einmal zwischen einer offenheit und den
kindern tatsächlich sagen da passiert
etwas schlimmes und auf der anderen
seite müssen wir ihnen ein
sicherheitsgefühl
vermitteln dass sie sich jetzt hier in
unserer familie in unserer umgebung ganz
sicher fühlen können es ist absolut
wichtig für kinder in dieser zeit und
trotzdem wir können es nicht von ihnen
fernhalten und für die kinder ihr auch
hier in deutschland oder in mitteleuropa
ist das eine ängstigen de situation ich
bedanke mich recht herzlich bei ihnen
dass sie sich heute morgen zeit genommen
haben und die einsichten geteilt haben
mit ihnen das war dr georg pieper
psychologe vielen dank
dann gehen und wenn sie liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer etwas tun
möchten den menschen in der ukraine
helfen möchten dann können sie das tun
und zwar beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe unter dem stichwort
zdf nothilfe ukraine unter bahn.de 65
104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
finden sie selbstverständlich auch auf
spenden punkt zdf.de und
an dieser stelle wollen wir christian
mölling noch einmal ins gespräch mit
einbinden den direktor des
forschungsinstituts der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
hermeling die wahrnehmung aktuell ist
dass die militär offensive bisher nicht
so schnell vorangekommen ist wie von
moskau vermutlich erhofft russische
truppen sind nämlich auf doch relativ
großen widerstand seitens der ukraine
gestoßen wie ordnen sie das ein ja ich
glaube muss als erstes mal sehen dass
man alle informationen die jetzt zu uns
kommen sehr mit mit mit sehr viel
vorsicht einfach genießen muss weil
natürlich jeder gerne sich in den
vordergrund spielen möchte er seine
erfolge und die misserfolge des anderen
ganz gerne sozusagen darstellen möchte
denn wir haben es zu 50 prozent schon
vor beginn des krieges mit
informationskrieg zu tun also hier
werden bilder miteinander ausgetauscht
und informationen auch über die medien
miteinander ausgetauscht aber man kann
sehr wohl annehmen dass die die moral
der ukrainischen streitkräfte aber auch
der zivilbevölkerung jetzt mit
einschätzt natürlich eine erhebliche
widerstandskraft mit ausmacht das ist
nichts nichts besonderes dass es in der
geschichte immer wieder so dass sie zwar
militärisch hoch gerüstet sein können
sie aber letztendlich auf einen massiven
gegenwind treffen und das macht krieg so
unberechenbar und das macht es auch für
putin unberechenbar deswegen sind wir
leute auch davon ausgegangen dass er
eigentlich so eine große offensive wir
sie jetzt gerade startet eigentlich
vielleicht besser nicht machen würde
hätte seine ziele auch anders erreichen
können wenn er sehr kleinen in der
salami taktik vorgegangen wäre aber
jetzt haben eine situation wo er sich
selber und seine streitkräfte
möglicherweise ein großes risiko gibt
sind ja viele die jetzt denken
eigentlich ist das das ende für putin
und sein land weil er sich so dermaßen
isoliert weil er geht ja bis ans
äußerste er ist bereit gewalt
einzusetzen um seine ziele zu erreichen
und
spekuliert darauf dass die gegenseite
dies eben nicht tut weil er mit seiner
mit seinem nuklearwaffenarsenals eben
eine enorme abschreckung bietet wie geht
das dann weiter dieses szenario kennt
man aus dem krieg 110 und die usa so der
westen und der osten standen sich so
gegenüber geht das alles jetzt wieder
von vorne los
so weit würde ich nicht gehen ich glaube
was wir aber wovon wir uns verabschieden
müssen ist die idee dass es so einen
zustand von krieg und frieden gibt ob es
denn jemals gegeben hat weiß ich nicht
aber es ist heute zumindest eine
romantische erzählung wenn dieser
schießt krieg den wir gerade sehen zu
ende gegangen ist wie auch immer jetzt
zu ende geht und wer durch komplett
einnahme der ukraine oder aber durch
eine kapitulation oder einen
friedensvertrag einen waffenstillstand
dann geht der konflikt mit russland ja
weiter wir haben hier nicht nur konflikt
nur über ein territorium sondern wir
haben ein konflikt über die frage wie
wollen wir in europa eigentlich
miteinander leben gilt das recht des
stärkeren oder gilt die stärke des
rechts hier in zukunft weiter und das
wird gerade in der ukraine natürlich
tatsächlich verhandelt aber wir sehen
jetzt schon dass wir es mit staaten zu
tun haben die bereit sind militärische
gewalt einzusetzen ihre politischen
ziele durchzusetzen
wir werden genau darüber im laufe
unserer sendung natürlich noch weiter
sprechen bis hierhin erst einmal vielen
dank
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio variiert von waldenfels
und mitri sirin
willkommen zu diesem zdf morgenmagazin
in einer xxl fassung und sowieso
außerplanmäßig weil samstag noch bis 10
uhr 30 live tag drei des krieges in der
ukraine und wir wollen zu beginn dieser
stunde jetzt einen o-ton vorspielen und
zwar von ukraine es präsident seelands
geht er sich vor wenigen augenblicken
selbst geäußert hat
guten morgen
glauben sie den fälschungen nicht es
gibt keine kapitulation
wir verteidigen unser land niemand wird
die waffen niederlegen es geht um unsere
wahrheit um unsere kinder um unsere
ukraine
das möchte ich euch sagen
und dieser ukrainische präsident lenski
hat außerdem auch ein angebot der usa
ausgeschlagen das land zu verlassen
kehrt von ihr sagte ich bleibe ich
möchte hier meine landsleute mit
unterstützen und das land verteidigen in
kiew der hauptstadt die so wichtig ist
so strategisch wichtig ist und die die
russlands präsident putin natürlich
einnehmen möchte da wird weiterhin
gekämpft und im zentrum ist ein
flugkörper in ein wohnhaus eingeschlagen
das sehen wir hier die rauchschwaden die
sieht man über der gesamten stadt und
hier wurden glaube ich wenn ich richtig
informiert bin der siebzehnte und 18
stockwerk massiv beschädigt und das hat
auch vor wenigen minuten der ukrainische
generalstab besteht die menschen das
finden auch noch mitteilen die sich noch
im haus befanden hier sehen die es die
in den sozialen netzwerken geteilt
werden diese bilder die werden aktuell
von der ukrainischen von den
ukrainischen truppen aus dem gebäude
gerettet wie viele bewohner durch den
einschlag des flugkörpers verletzt oder
getötet wurden dazu können wir keine
angaben über die situation vor ort über
die reaktionen anderswo internationalen
reaktionen werden wir gleich weiter
sprechen und uns damit beschäftigen
schauen uns jetzt nochmal die themen
gesamt im überblick an
schlacht um kiew erbitterter widerstand
in der ukrainischen hauptstadt
flüchtlingswelle warten und hoffen an
den grenzen zur ukraine und
krisengipfel die nächsten schritte von
uno und nato
wir lassen das ganze selbstverständlich
einordnen jederzeit aktuell von unseren
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
vor ort haben aber auch politische
gespräche geführt unter anderem schon
mit sergey lagodinsky dem russland
politischen sprecher der grünen fraktion
im eu parlament auch der neue csu
generalsekretär stephan mayer war uns
bereits zugeschaltet und wir haben noch
geplant ein gespräch mit oliver müller
von der caritas international ihn werden
wir fragen wasser wird von seinen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern aus
der ukraine wie es den menschen dort
geht und wie man ihnen helfen kann alle
gespräche können sich auch auf der zd
erfreute dann nochmal anschauen unter
anderem auch ein gespräch mit lettlands
präsident heute bei uns im zdf
morgenmagazin der sich bald deutschland
bedankt für den einsatz der nato einsatz
die ostflanke noch mal stärker zu
unterstützen
militärisch jetzt sind wir bei den
nachrichten habe ich ein richter hat die
hinter heute express wir dann noch mal
hallo guten morgen guten morgen ja hallo
guten morgen zurück wie ordner das ganze
jetzt nochmal in die kurzform schauen
wir zunächst auf die situation in der
ukraine wo auch rund um die hauptstadt
kiew gekämpft wird nach behördenangaben
gibt es in mehreren stadtteilen
straßenkämpfe und beschuss die
bevölkerung soll schutzräume aufsuchen
und dort bleiben
am morgen meldete sich präsident sie
lenski erneut mit einer video botschaft
darin forderte er die menschen zum
durchhalten auf er selbst werde auf
jeden fall in kiew bleiben
im un-sicherheitsrat ist eine resolution
gescheitert die den angriff auf die
ukraine verurteilen sollte wie erwartet
legte russland bei der abstimmung ein
veto ein china indien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate
enthielten sich die restlichen elf
staaten stimmten für den text
die nato verstärkt ihre ostflanke weiter
und schickt teile der schnellen
eingreiftruppe in die dortigen
mitgliedsländer deutschland will eine
kompanie in die slowakei verlegen
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg sagte
man werde alles tun um jeden verbündeten
und jeden zentimeter nato gebiet zu
verteidigen
unterdessen verhandeln moskau und kiew
über direkte gespräche dabei geht es vor
allem um den ort des treffens russland
hatte die belarussische hauptstadt minsk
vorgeschlagen was die ukrainische
regierung ablehnt nun hat sich ungarn
als gastgeber angeboten in die orgien
hauptstadt tiflis haben am abend
zehntausende gegen den russischen
einmarsch in die ukraine protestiert und
30.000 menschen schwenkten ukrainische
und georgische flaggen und sangen die
nationalhymnen der beiden länder
georgiens bestreben nato mitglied zu
werden sorgt wie bei der ukraine seit
jahren für konflikte mit russland
schauen wir noch kurz aufs thema corona
denn heute starten die ersten nowaks
impfungen und zwar in hamburg
schleswig-holstein und dem saarland das
vakzin soll vorrangig beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen angeboten werden dort
gilt ab mitte märz eine einrichtung zum
pflicht als sogenannter proteine im
stoff bietet novara nowaks denjenigen
eine alternative die der m rna
technologie skeptisch gegenüberstehen
und was uns dieses wochenende
wettermäßig bringt das sagt ihnen
binjamin stellt
vielen dank herr server und guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen zum wetter wenn wir
auf die europakarte blicken dann sehen
wir zwischen grönland island und den
britischen inseln
windgeschwindigkeiten in orkanstärke die
zeigt uns der wind film hier rot
eingefärbt schwerer sturm auch bis zur
norwegischen küste nichts davon erreicht
uns es ist das hochdruckgebiet über
mitteleuropa dass uns die
tiefdruckgebiete und deren einfluss auf
abstand hält sehr ruhige sehr sonnige
tage stehen uns bevor allerdings morgens
beginnen die meist mit nebel
beziehungsweise hochnebel das ist heute
morgen der fall im westen und im osten
und bei temperaturen teilweise deutlich
unter null grad vorsicht auf den straßen
überfrierende nässe ist ein thema heute
morgen die temperaturen zum start in dem
samstag aktuell gemessen - 74 grad
meldet stühlingen an der grenze zur
schweiz fünf grad plus sind es heute
morgen auf norderney und damit sind wir
beim wettergeschehen am vormittag von
westen her wird es jetzt immer
freundlicher am meisten sonnenschein
gibt es heute morgen schon im nordwesten
im osten sind die wolken noch dicht und
im stau des erzgebirges und der alpen
verklingen die schnee beziehungsweise
schneeregenschauer der nacht das wird
sich zum nachmittag alles aufgelöst
haben dann bekommt auch die wolkendecke
über im osten mehr und mehr lücken die
sonne hat mehr chancen sich blicken zu
lassen das ganze bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute zwischen
zwei grad richtung alpenrand bis 10 grad
verbreitet im nordwesten und die
aussichten für die kommenden drei tage
die sehen ähnlich aus der hochnebel muss
sich lösen dann wird es morgen im ganzen
land sehr freundlich vier bis elf grad
am montag ähnliche verhältnisse am
dienstag von nordwesten neuer wolken und
neuer regen bei sechs bis zwölf grad
sehr mild so weit zum wetter für den
moment kommen sie mit diesen aussichten
jetzt gut in den samstag
[Musik]
willkommen an diesem außergewöhnlichen
samstagmorgen und zu einem zdf
morgenmagazin das ist in dieser form so
noch nicht gegeben hat an einem samstag
und wisent noch bis 10 uhr 30 live
möglicherweise harry jetzt sitzen viele
andere jetzt beim frühstück haben das ei
und die zeitung und wenn wir heute
morgen in die zeitungen blicken das
können sie sich vorstellen da gibt es
natürlich nur ein thema aus allen
möglichen perspektiven wird dieser
angriffskrieg russlands auf die ukraine
beleuchtet ja im russischen
angriffskrieg konzentrieren sich die
kämpfe gerade muss man sagen auf die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew auch in
dieser nacht schüsse auch in dieser
nacht kämpfe am stadtrand der präsident
sie lenski rief die bewohner auf die
stadt zu verteidigen und noch das
offenbar sind die führungen in kiew und
moskau gerade in kontakt über gespräche
russlands präsident putin hat selensky
ein gespräch in weißrussland angeboten
allerdings nicht er persönlich sondern
eine russische delegation und
außenministerin annalena baerbock nannte
das gesprächsangebot vergiftet über die
ereignisse der nacht und die aktuelle
lage tim kröger und annette streiche
über menschenleeren straßen ist ein
neuer morgen angebrochen noch ist kiew
nicht gefallen doch schüsse durchbrechen
die stille rauchschwaden einschläge und
explosionen auch schon in der nacht
immer näher am zentrum der
unabhängigkeitsplatz wie lange kann er
noch verteidigt werden am abend hatte
der ukrainische präsident seine bürger
auf entscheidende stunden vorbereitet
wir dürfen unsere hauptstadt nicht
verlieren appellierte er obwohl er
selbst um sein leben fürchten muss und
macht jetzt hoffnung mit einer neuen
botschaft aus der dämmerung wir werden
die waffen nicht niederlegen wir werden
unseren staat verteidigen sagt er
kiew das hauptziel der russischen
invasion die russischen einheiten rücken
vor allem von norden an die stadt heran
der kreml wolle die ukrainische führung
ablösen und eine marionettenregierung
installieren so die lesart vieler
beobachter am späten abend schildert ein
notfallmediziner aus kiew im zdf die
situation
können sie uns sagen wie viele opfer des
krieges sie jetzt bereits behandeln
mussten in der staat erhört man dass
geschossen wird und
man hört auch explosionen
weil wir haben einen improvisierten
bunker leider müssen die bettlägerigen
patienten in den zimmern bleiben
und wir bieten immer an den gott dass er
kein geschoss zu uns kommt ein winziger
hoffnungsschimmer vielleicht laut
facebook seite eines sprechers der
ukrainischen führung werde gerade mit
den russen über mögliche verhandlungen
verhandelt ausgang noch immer ungewiss
noch aber ist das die realität
russische truppen greifen die ukraine
von mehreren seiten an inaktiv etwa
stellen sich ihnen ukrainische soldaten
entgegen
detonationen in der nähe angst auf den
straßen
dieser vater zeit wieder vorhang seine
tochter vor den zersplitternden fenstern
bewahrt habe
wir mussten in der u-bahn-station
schlafen es war sehr voll menschen saßen
auf stühlen wir bleiben an einem platz
weil dort ein süßer hund war den mochte
ich sehr
fahrradhelme gegen bomben u bahnhöfe und
heizungskeller werden zu schutzräumen
viele sehen nur noch die flucht als
ausweg nach einschätzung der vereinten
nationen versuchen derzeit
hunderttausende noch das land zu
verlassen der präsident bleibt hat
us-amerikanischen informationen zufolge
abgelehnt sich in sicherheit bringen zu
lassen wohl mit den worten er brauche
munition keine mitfahrgelegenheit
unterdessen hat der us-präsident den weg
frei gemacht für über 300 millionen euro
militärischer soforthilfe der widerstand
der ukraine geht weiter
für uns in der ukraine und zwar
südwestlich von kiew befindet sich
katrin eigendorf guten morgen kathrin
gerade hat sich der bürgermeister von
kiew vitali klitschko gemeldet und hat
sich ähnlich geäussert wie präsident sie
lenski und er sagt wir werden
durchhalten es wird schwierig aber wir
müssen uns verteidigen mit der armee und
mit unserer justiz was bekommen sie von
der bedrohungslage aktuell mit
die bedrohungslage ist weiter gewachsen
es spitzt sich alles darauf zu dass kiew
wohl von den russen eingenommen werden
soll es wird auch in vielen anderen
städten gekämpft aber das hauptaugenmerk
der russen liegt natürlich darauf jetzt
die hauptstadt einzunehmen ihr ziel ist
den präsidenten im prinzip zu entmachten
aber was wir jetzt hier sehen und
erleben und es gibt wirklich sehr sehr
viele quellen das ist wahrscheinlich der
einer der am besten dokumentierten
kriege der geschichte es gibt wahnsinnig
viele quellen die davon sprechen wie die
bevölkerung widerstand leistet es ist
nicht nur die ukrainische armee die hier
den russen entgegentritt sondern auch
viele ukraine haben zu den waffen
gegriffen es gibt um weibliche
solidarität was wir hier erleben viele
leute die sagen wir bleiben ich bin
ärztin ich kann das land nicht verlassen
ich muss jetzt hier bleiben
es geht für die menschen und dafür steht
ja im prinzip auch see lenski als
präsident darum die zukunft ihres landes
hier zu sichern und das ist nicht nur
die führung also ein bürgermeister wie
klitschko bürgermeister auch anderer
städte und gouverneure der präsident die
dafür stehen sondern ich glaube das wird
auch unterstützt von einer ganz ganz
großen bevölkerungsschicht es ist nicht
so dass sich hier die leute massenhaft
auf die flucht machen es gibt natürlich
fluchtbewegungen auf die sich europa
einstellen muss aber ich denke präsident
putin muss damit rechnen dass er ganz
ganz erbitterten widerstand von der
ukraine bekommt das führt mich zur
zweiten frage kathrin erst gestern
wieder eine absurde ansprache des
russischen präsidenten putin gegeben
unter anderem mit der aufforderung an
das ukrainische militär zu putzen gibt
es darauf schon irgendwelche reaktionen
haben sie irgendetwas mitbekommen
nein darauf gibt es keine reaktionen
offiziell
dieses diese diese aufforderung zeigt
für mich persönlich wie sehr putin doch
verkennt wie die gemütslage der mehrheit
der bevölkerung hier in der ukraine ist
das land ist seit acht jahren im krieg
die bevölkerung sieht russland wirklich
als große bedrohung und als feind und
hier zu glauben dass das ukrainische
militär gegen eine gewählte regierung
putschen könnte finde ich doch sehr
erstaunlich ich weiß nicht wann putin
das letzte mal die ukraine besucht hat
und wie seine einschätzung der lage ist
aber es scheint mir nicht sehr
realistisch was er glaubt ihr
unternehmen zu können die ukraine wird
meiner einschätzung nach erbitterten
widerstand leisten und wir haben das
erlebt es ist eine bevölkerung die hat
in den letzten 20 jahren zwei
regierungen gestürzt auch die eroberung
des ostens der ukraine war für die
russen relativ schwierig da haben sich
zu anfang sogar bevölkerungsgruppen den
russischen militärs entgegengestellt und
das ist einfach eine situation mit der
muss putin rechnen dass es hierzu ganz
ganz erbitterten kämpfen kommen wird
gibt weiter auf sich acht katrin
eigendorf war das live aus dem südwesten
der ukraine vielen dank
putin ist verkennt die gemütslage des
ukrainischen volkes haben wir von katrin
eigendorf gehört da wollen wir meine
reaktion zu erfragen und zwar direkt in
moskau von unserer korrespondentin anna
fast denn anna man hat hier tatsächlich
den eindruck die russischen truppen
kommen nicht so schnell voran wie putin
sich das vielleicht erhofft hat eben
weil die ukraine doch mehr widerstand
leistet als erwartet wie wird das in
russland wahrgenommen und diskutiert
ja das wird hier natürlich komplett
anders wahrgenommen und diskutiert die
meldungen die hier über die russischen
nachrichtenagenturen larven sind
erfolgsmeldungen da wird vermeldet dass
man eben jetzt 30 kilometer ins inland
30 kilometer auf ukrainisch kontrolliert
das gebiet im donbass in den regionen
donezk und nur hans vorgedrungen sei da
wird kommuniziert dass man mit otto pöhl
eingenommen habe da wird kommuniziert
das ist gefechte gebe um odessa da wird
kommuniziert welche ziele oder welche
ukrainische militärische infrastruktur
man alles zerstört habe also es ist mehr
oder weniger dass das das gegenteil das
komplette von dem was von ukrainischer
seite zu hören ist und das befolgt
natürlich also natürlich im i-punkt sich
hier als sieger oder als stärkerer
inszenieren und das ist das was wir hier
eben über die offiziellen russischen
kanäle kommuniziert bekommen putin hat
ja zudem gesprächsbereitschaft
signalisiert allerdings muss man das
unter vorsicht so äußern denn er stellt
ganz bestimmte bedingungen also wie
erfolgsversprechend kann sowas überhaupt
sein und wie ernst kann man das auch
nennen
ja dieses gesprächsangebot von putin ist
kein neues das angebot wurde lanciert am
donnerstag und zwar von lukaschenko der
sprach davon er hätte mit putin
gesprochen und putin sei eben bereit
diesen krieg zu stoppen
friedensverhandlungen jungen zu führen
unter zwei bedingungen bedingungen
nummer eins die ukraine rücken ab von
einer nato mitgliedschaft und die
ukraine werde komplett
demilitarisiert dann als ort für diese
gespräche wurde minsk vorgeschlagen und
diese gesprächsbereitschaft wurde dann
in den folgenden stunden immer wieder
erneuert immer wieder wiederholt von
russischer seite
als lenski dann ebenfalls um ein
gespräch bat so das russische narrativ
hätte putin sofort zum telefonhörer
gegriffen und sofort den weißrussischen
präsidenten lukaschenko
angerufen und eben minsk vorgeschlagen
noch mal dann hätte aber selensky gesagt
er wolle warschau und sei daraufhin
nicht mehr ans telefon gegangen das ist
das negativ was hier verbreitet wird was
hier erzählt wird man kann festhalten
dass das keine offene
gesprächsbereitschaft ist weil die eben
diese zwei bedingungen geknüpft ist
annafest mit informationen aus moskau
vielen dank für den augenblick
ja es ist eine fürchterliche eine
bedrückende situation vor allem für die
menschen in der ukraine die ukraine hat
ungefähr halb so viele einwohner wie wir
hier also circa 40 millionen
und sie wissen was das heißt das dass
millionen menschen die sich jetzt
aufmachen richtung westen und viele
natürlich erst einmal in die
nachbarländer zum beispiel nach polen
ungarn rumänien moldawien oder in die
slowakei und genau von dort berichtet
jetzt britta hilpert
nach diesem schlagbaum sind sie in
sicherheit in ihrer heimat ukraine
wissen krieg wie schnell im netz ist
slowakei ist eu da sind verwandte
freunde die sich hier abholen
erleichtert
es sind nur frauen und kinder die an der
grenze entstehen männer müssen bleiben
und kämpfen
nina kommt aus der nähe von kiew
sie haben meinen mann mitgenommen
erzählt sie die unsere mein vater mein
bruder sie sollen kämpfen und dann sagt
sie wie im schock unser haus ist dort
gebrannt
an der grenze stehen die ukraine sascha
und eduard sie arbeiten seit jahren in
tschechien und sind hergekommen um zu
helfen wie hunderte andere dinge
bieten denen die aus der ukraine kommen
kostenlosen transport nach prag wir tun
es ein paar schritte weiter wartet
marcus ein ukraine auf bekannte aus der
heimat er werde nicht kämpfen sagt er
die keine kämpfe bruder gegen bruder das
ist unmöglich die russin
anastassia kommt ohne ihren mann er
blieb der alten eltern wegen und volvo
kämpfen muss sie hatte so gehofft dass
es so weit nicht kommt
ich will nicht sagen dass ich was gegen
das russische volk haben es ist nur die
russische regierung es ist nur politik
daran sind die menschen nicht schon
ihr sohn ist vier monate alt und heißt
wladimir
ausgerechnet er wird nun aufwachsen in
einer anderen ukrainischen wind
und wenn sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer sich jetzt fragen wie sie den
menschen in der ukraine helfen können
dann können sie das tun zum beispiel
beim aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine die bahn
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
dazu auch auf spenden von zdf.de oder
auf der zdf textseite
890 ja die frage was kann man tun dass
beschäftigt natürlich auch die politik
da geht es dann in erster linie um
sanktionen und in zusammenhang mit
sanktionen gegen russland wird schon
seit längerem gefordert russland auch
vom zahlungssysteme swift abzukoppeln
unter anderem deutschland lehnt das aber
noch ab ja diese maßnahme da einzusetzen
ernte dafür allerdings auch viel kritik
nicht nur international sondern auch
hier in deutschland trifft das ist ein
weltweites transaktions system mit dem
quasi so muss man sich das vorstellen
alle bargeldlosen zahlen abgewickelt
also zahlung entschuldigung abgewickelt
werden mehr zutrifft erfahren wir jetzt
von natalie wollmann
wenn irgendwo auf der welt eine
auslandsüberweisung stattfindet kommt
swift ins spiel mit dem eigentlichen
bankgeschäft hat das nichts zu tun der
kommunikationsdienstleister sorgt an
seinem eher unscheinbaren sitz in der
nähe brüssels vielmehr dafür dass
informationen über zahlungen sicher und
schnell ausgetauscht werden im zentrum
stehen dabei standardisierte formulare
mit dem identifikations code bic der nur
zu einer einzigen bank führt er besteht
aus elf zeichen die ersten vier stehen
für den bank nahm dann kommt der
ländercode dann die ortskennung und
gegebenfalls die vier jahre kennung oder
einfach 3x verwechslung ausgeschlossen
weltweit sind 11.000 banken und
finanzkonzerne in über 200 ländern in
diesem netzwerk miteinander verbunden
auf grundlage der swift informationen
buchen sie zahlungen und es hilft kann
ein land kaum geld empfangen oder zahlen
und der handel wäre so extrem erschwert
wir wollen weiter darüber sprechen uns
das einordnen lassen von stefan kooths
vom kieler institut für weltwirtschaft
schönen guten morgen hallo guten morgen
die russische zentralbank hat berechnet
dass die wirtschaftsleistung in russland
ohne swift um fünf prozent einbrechen
würde ist ein ausschluss russlands von
swift für moskau also verschmerzbar nein
das ist auf dauer nicht verschmerzbar
grundsätzlich müssen wir uns ja klar
machen dass swift nur ein platzhalter
ist dafür russland aus weiten teilen der
weltwirtschaft
herauszulösen und dann fehlen eben
wichtige zulieferungen und zum anderen
kann man auch die eigenen rohstoffe
nicht mehr so ohne weiteres verkaufen
also darum geht es eigentlichen die
wirtschaftliche verflechtung russlands
herauszunehmen das wirft ein instrument
aber es gebe auch andere instrumente die
man einsetzen kann die denselben effekt
hätten und deshalb ist das die
eigentliche frage aber es heißt
zumindest so es sei ein richtig eine
harte maßnahme somit die härteste
sanktion die man verabschieden kann nun
haben deutschland italien und frankreich
sich auf dem treffen beim
außenministertreffen gegen so einen
ausschluss russlands gestellt warum ja
das sieht auf den ersten blick aus als
würde hier so eine krämer mentalität
herrschen dass einem das zu teuer wäre
das greift meines erachtens aber zu kurz
wir müssen ja sehen dass unterbrechen
dann insbesondere der gaslieferungen ist
für uns kurzfristig betrachtet
schmerzhafter als für die russische
seite und langfristig ist es genau
andersherum das heißt es geht jetzt bei
den sanktionen auch darum das richtige
timing zu finden solange das gas noch
fließt desto eher haben wir die
möglichkeit uns umzustellen zu
geringeren kosten und das ist schon ein
wichtiger aspekt den wir nicht übersehen
sollten langfristig oder generell die
zeit spielt gegen
putin und wir sollten jetzt nicht das
ist natürlich populär verständlich dass
man jetzt erstmal so ja vergeltungs
reflexe hat aber es kommt jetzt nicht
darauf an möglichst schnell zu reagieren
sondern möglichst wirksam zu reagieren
am ende ist militärische macht auch
immer eine frage der wirtschaftskraft
und je mehr sich dort das gefälle zu
gunsten des westens noch weiter
verschiebt desto eher können wir auch
der ukraine helfen wir machen die
ukraine nicht oder wenig helfen der
ukraine nicht dadurch dass wir uns
schwach machen sondern dadurch dass wir
uns stark machen und zwar stärker als
russland herr kurz versuchen sie mal das
so zu erklären dass wir es verstehen
wenn ich sie frage wenn deutschland über
50 prozent des erdgases aus russland
beziehen wir russland abkoppeln würden
von diesem system wie würden wir
russland dann bezahlen würde dass
möglicherweise auch mit gütern gehen
oder wie müsste man sich das vorstellen
das kann man sich im extremfall auch
vorstellen wobei sie noch nicht die idee
ist einfach nur die zahlungsweise zu
ersetzen wir wollen ja tatsächlich
russland herauslösen aus der
weltwirtschaft das heißt wir wollen ja
die handelsströme am ende des tages
wirklich wirksam unterbrechen das
schadet russland auf lange sicht sehr
und zwar viel mehr als uns und im
zweifel könnte man jetzt auch mit bata
geschäften und dergleichen weitermachen
aber noch einmal es geht ja gar nicht
darum primär die zahlungsströme zu
unterbrechen es geht darum die
handelsströme zu unterbrechen und jetzt
trifft abzuschalten und gleichzeitig
wege drumherum zu finden das trotzdem
der handel weiter stattfinden kann das
wäre ja in sich widersprüchlich letzte
frage an sie herr code putin hat in den
letzten jahren die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu china auf
ausgebaut und aufgebaut wenn jetzt
russland isoliert es sich jetzt zu china
hin wendet sozusagen dann den
ausfallenden handel mit china dann
sozusagen betreibt auch vielleicht
gelder und kredite von china erhält und
gleichzeitig so ist zumindest zu hören
selber ein wahnsinniges volumen an
devisen reserven aufgebaut hat man liest
hier 640 milliarden us-dollar würde
russland alleine klar kommen ohne den
westen russland würde gegenüber dem
westen weiter und zwar noch weiter
zurückfallen russland ab jetzt schon
dramatisch unter den möglichkeiten gehen
das land hätte wenn es gut regiert würde
wenn man dort eine offene freie markt
wirtschaftliche entwicklung hätte all
das hat putin jetzt schon in kauf
genommen dass das land wie gesagt weit
unter seinen möglichkeiten bleibt und
china kann das nicht ersetzen
china würde im zweifel russland dann als
willkommen den rohstofflieferanten
betrachten viel mehr aber auch nicht
also die weltwirtschaftliche integration
bleibt für russland die achillesferse
über eine abkopplung von swift von
russland und mögliche konsequenzen haben
wir gesprochen mit stefan kooths vom
kieler institut für weltwirtschaft
vielen dank und noch einen angenehmen
samstag sehr gerne für sie auch
es ist kurz vor halb zehn an diesem
samstag wir senden ja liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer hier
gemeinsam mit den kollegen von der ard
und in wenigen augenblicken verlässt uns
die ard wenn sie weiter interesse haben
dann können sie das gerne weiter im zdf
verfolgen bis 10 uhr 30 an dieser stelle
machen wir weiter mit einer politischen
analyse und zwar mit unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten karl
hinterleitner und der frage wie soll
dann in deutschland auf diese krise
jetzt reagieren ihrer meinung nach es
gibt ja deutliche äußerungen was die
ausrichtung der künftigen außen und
sicherheitspolitik angeht findet er
gerade ein umdenken in der
verteidigungspolitik statt
ja das kann man sagen da hat der beginn
einer zeitenwende stattgefunden
angefangen hat die diskussion so kann
man glaube ich sagen mit antrieb zwar
von der ehemalige verteidigungsminister
in anrath kramp karrenbauer die schrieb
ich bin so wütend auf uns wir haben es
verpasst deutschland
verteidigungsfähigkeit halten wir haben
das alles falsch eingeschätzt etwas
ähnliches filme vom finanzminister der
sagt wir haben an die friedensdividende
geglaubt nach dem kalten krieg gedacht
wir brauchen verteidigung nicht mehr wir
können das andere den usa überlassen und
darüber eben diese aufgabe der
landesverteidigung vernachlässigt das
müsse jetzt geändert werden und das ist
ein thema das jetzt massiv aufgekommen
ist wir waren zu naiv im umgang mit
russland sagt auch der
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck der
ist also eine gewisse einigkeit es gibt
aber auch schon widerspruch zum beispiel
rolf mützenich
spd der dem widersprochen hat man müsse
nicht mehr für die bundeswehr aufwenden
also das alles ist ein thema das andere
thema sind waffenlieferungen die man
ausgeschlossen wurden jetzt von manchen
befürwortet werden auch da gab es ein
umdenken man muss dazu sagen dass alles
nicht schnell zu lösen deutsche waffen
für die ukraine käme zu spät und eine
züchtigung der bundeswehr die würde
jahre dauern aber die diskussion die ist
eben jetzt da und die wird die neue
ampel regierung noch beschäftigen
und beschäftigen tun uns auch die
sonstigen reaktionen zum beispiel was
die sanktionen angeht die verhängt
wurden oder eben auch nicht verhängt
wurden denn eine scharfe sanktionen und
so weit wollte man noch nicht gehen ist
der ausschluss russlands aus dem
internationalen zahlungssystems hilft ja
dazu konnte man sich noch nicht
entschließen die usa sind dafür die
europäer sind sich uneins und die
bundesregierung zögerlich sage ich mal
bis zurückhaltend der bundeskanzler aber
zum beispiel auch die fdp und hier gibt
es schon den ersten gegenwind aus den
eigenen reihen so hat heute franziska
brandmann die vorsitzende der jungen
liberalen den bundeskanzler und die
eigene partei kritisiert wegen dieser
zögerlichkeit man müsse jetzt daran man
müsse alle sanktionen auf den tisch
legen und schrift schnell installieren
ob das richtig ist ob das realistisch
ist ich beziehe mich darauf mein
vorredner auf stefan kurz vorm
weltwirtschaftsinstitut der sagt
kurzfristig schadet eine kappung der
erdgaslieferung beispielsweise uns mehr
langfristig schadet sie russland mehr es
käme also nicht so sehr auch schnell ist
sondern auch wirksames handeln an was da
das richtige ist darüber gibt es durch
diskussion jetzt auch innerhalb der
bundesregierung
karl hinterleitner mit einer politischen
einordnung vielen dank dafür
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio
wird von waldenfels und mitri sirin
einen schönen guten tag von uns von zdf
morgenmagazin außerplanmäßig an diesem
samstag ist natürlich den aktuellen
ereignissen in der ukraine geschuldet
wir sind noch bis 10 uhr 30 live es gibt
eine jahr finde ich aufsehenerregende
meldungen und des ukrainischen
präsidenten der sich via twitter
geäußert hat und
er hat die aufnahme seines landes in die
eu gefordert tatsächlich und ich bin mal
gespannt wie darauf die reaktionen
ausfallen und er hat sich vor
einiger zeit auch geäußert ich glaube
vereint zwei stunden und wir hören mal
rein was er gesagt hat nicht dazu zu
etwas anderem
guten morgen
glauben sie den fälschungen nicht es
gibt keine kapitulation
wir verteidigen unser land niemand wird
die waffen niederlegen es geht um unsere
wahrheit um unsere kinder um unsere
ukraine
das möchte ich euch sagen
wir wissen nicht ob diese rettungsaktion
beendet ist und an anderen vielen
stellen gibt es auch schusswechsel und
explosionen
wir haben heute morgen schon viele viele
gespräche geführt unter anderem mit
lettlands präsidenten sie wissen
lettland grenzt ja auch an russland und
auch an weißrussland und er bedankt sich
ausdrücklich heute bei uns im interview
bei deutschland für die unterstützung
für die nato unterstützung deutschland
verlegt ja weitere truppen bzw auch
gerät dorthin dann noch ein blick auf
unsere weiteren gesprächsgäste von heute
sergey lagodinsky bei uns zugeschaltete
russland politische sprecher der grünen
fraktion im eu parlament selbst russland
stämmiger deutscher mit ihm haben wir
darüber gesprochen wie er sich fühlt wie
es ihnen geht und wie er die situation
politisch auch einschätzt ebenso haben
wir gesprochen mit stephan mayer dem
neuen csu generalsekretär da ging es
auch unter anderem um den zustand der
bundeswehr und gleich planen wir noch
ein gespräch mit oliver müller von der
caritas international er hat viele
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter aktuell
in der ukraine wir wollen fragen wie es
denen geht und was sie berichten von den
menschen vor ort es gibt hohen
informationsbedarf nachrichten jetzt
kurz und kompakt von unseren heute
express kollegen kreisel berichte und
wir sagen guten morgen hallo noch mal
und ich sage guten morgen da bin ich
jetzt auch zurück und liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer an sie
guten morgen wir schauen zunächst auf
die situation in der ukraine selbst wo
auch rund um die hauptstadt kiew
gekämpft werden sie haben es gesehen
nach behördenangaben gibt es in mehreren
stadtteilen straßenkämpfe und beschuss
die bevölkerung soll schutzräume
aufsuchen und dort bleiben präsident
jens gemeldete sich am morgen erneut mit
einer video botschaft darin forderte er
die menschen zum durchhalten auf er
selbst werde auf jeden fall in kiew
bleiben
im un-sicherheitsrat ist eine resolution
gescheitert die den angriff auf die
ukraine verurteilen sollte wie erwartet
legte russland bei der abstimmung ein
veto ein china indien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate
enthielten sich die restlichen elf
staaten stimmten für den text
die nato verstärkt ihre ostflanke weiter
und schickt teile der schnellen
eingreiftruppen in die dortige mit wir
benötigen mitgliedsländer deutschland
will eine kompanie in die slowakei
verlegen
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg sagte
man werde alles tun um jeden verbündeten
und jeden zentimeter nato gebet zu
verteidigen
zehntausende sind bereits vor den
kämpfen geflüchtet allein nach polen
seien in den vergangenen 24 stunden 35
1000 menschen gekommen so die regierung
in warschau auch an der ukraine
slowakischen grenze versammeln sich
viele die sich in sicherheit bringen
wollen von dort berichtet unsere
korrespondentin britta hilpert die leute
kommen jetzt den einem schnelleren takt
kann man sagen gestern kamen sie immer
so schubweise auch jetzt ist sie sind es
immer noch schien es heißt nur 30 leute
kennen abgefertigt werden in einer
halben stunde war tatsächlich auf
ukrainischer seite genau kontrolliert
wird und auch die slowakische macht noch
zollkontrollen das erscheint mir
unglaublich es ist von wartezeiten die
rede von zwei bis zwölf stunden habe ich
schon alles gehört
unterdessen verhandeln moskau und kiew
über direkte gespräche dabei geht es vor
allem um den ort des treffens russland
hatte die belarussische hauptstadt minsk
vorgeschlagen was die ukrainische
regierung ablehnt nun hat sich ungarn
als gastgeber angeboten
in georgiens hauptstadt tiflis haben am
abend zehntausende gegen den russischen
einmarsch in die ukraine protestiert und
30.000 menschen schwenkten ukrainische
und georgische flagge und sangen die
nationalhymnen der beiden länder
georgiens bestreben nato mitglied zu
werden sorgt wie bei der ukraine seit
jahren für konflikte mit russland
immerhin beim wetter gibt es lichtblicke
wenn ihr mit stöver hat die wochenende
[Musik]
vielen dank herr wirren guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen zum wetter am
samstag und in der tat es ist jetzt zu
nehmende hochdruckeinfluss der uns in
den nächsten tagen ruhiges trockenes und
sonniges wetter beschert der satelliten
film zeigt uns das hoch über
mitteleuropa von frankreich in unsere
richtung drängt im moment noch auf der
ostseite dieses hochdruckgebiet kalte
luft zu uns unterwegs aus dem norden
aber perspektivisch hält dieses
hochdruckgebiet in der tat jeden
tiefdruckeinfluss auf abstand heute
morgen geht es los mit folgenden aktuell
gemessenen temperaturen balderschwang im
oberallgäu meldet im moment minus drei
grad plus sechs grad sind es auf
norderney und gerade richtung süden wo
die temperaturen um die null oder
darunter liegen seien sie vorsichtig
überfrierende nässe ist heute morgen ein
thema dazu der nebel im westen und der
hochnebel im osten der blick auf den
vormittag zeigt uns dann auch im stau
des erzgebirges und des allgäus
verklingen die letzten schnee
beziehungsweise schneeregenschauer der
nacht von westen wird schon sonniger die
meiste sonne gibt es heute morgen
bereits im nordwesten von dort nimmt das
im tagesverlauf auch weiter zu dann löst
sich auch die wolkendecke im osten immer
öfter die sonne hat gute chancen sich
blicken zu lassen bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute zwischen 2
grad am alpenrand bis 10 grad verbreitet
im nordwesten und damit sind wir bei den
aussichten für die kommenden drei tage
wenn sich der hochnebel morgen löst im
osten und im westen ein sehr
freundlicher tag vier bis elf grad
gleiche tendenz am montag vier bis elf
grad am dienstag dann von nordwesten
neue wolken neuer regen noch milder
sechs bis zwölf grad soweit zum wetter
für den moment kommen sie mit diesen
aussichten jetzt gut in den samstag
[Musik]
das zdf morgenmagazin an diesem samstag
auch heute wollen wir so umfassend wie
möglich über die russische invasion in
die ukraine berichten die kämpfe finden
natürliche und vermindert stadt von 3
flanken aber es konzentriert sich gerade
sehr sehr viel auf die ukrainische
hauptstadt kiew und vor dort hat sich
auch der bürgermeister vitali klitschko
gemeldet und hat sich ähnlich wie der
ukrainische präsident geäußert man
müsste jetzt zusammenhalten
zusammenstehen berichtet dass da nicht
viel russisches militär zu sehen ist
allerdings viele saboteure offenkundig
und dazu wollen wir direkt nachfragen
bei katrin eigendorf uns hinzugeschaltet
aus der ukraine ich wiederhole noch mal
die russischen truppen kommen offenbar
langsamer voran als putin das erhofft
hat und wir uns gerade gesagt vitali
klitschko der bürgermeister aus kiew
sieht keine größere russische
militärpräsenz in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt allerdings eine gruppe von
saboteuren was wissen sie über die lage
ja das ist nicht neu das hat sich im
prinzip auch gestern schon abgezeichnet
dass sehr viele saboteure so werden sie
von der ukrainischen regierung
bezeichnet das sind undercover-agenten
kann man im prinzip sagen die die russen
hier in zivil teilweise in die städte
schicken vor allem nach kiew aber wohl
auch in andere städte die die städte
auskundschaften dort auch im prinzip
einen einmarsch der militärs vorbereiten
auch hier in nizza das 200 kilometer von
kiew entfernt ist wurden gestern zwei
saboteure festgenommen bilder wurden
hier im internet auch davon
veröffentlicht das sind leute die hier
wirklich markieren wo sind entscheidende
stellen wo können die russischen
militärs reingehen was sind im prinzip
wichtige infrastrukturelemente das ist
eine strategie die russland wie gesagt
nicht erst seit heute verfolgt aber die
wohl mit dem zunehmenden sagen wir mal
problemen
die die bodentruppen haben hier im land
aufgrund des doch erbitterten
widerstandes der ukraine immer häufiger
an wänden eine zweite strategie von der
wir jetzt aus verschiedenen quellen
wissen ist dass russland wohl
tschetschenische kämpfer das muss man
sich vorstellen sind im prinzip söldner
hier einsetzt weil jedoch wesentlich
skrupelloser gegen die ukrainische
bevölkerung und auch die armee vorgehen
die sind wohl auch in kiew im einsatz
ukrainische präsident selensky hat sich
ja des öfteren mit hilfe besuchen an den
westen schon gewarnt in den letzten
tagen jetzt haben wir vor kurzem die
meldungen bekommen erbittet die auf
bittet um aufnahme in die eu was wissen
sie dazu
das ist ja ein teil von selen sqeez
strategie dass er sein land die
sicherheit seines landes und auch die
zukunft seines landes in der eu in der
nato sieht und dass er sich damit das
ist ja im prinzip auch die grundlage des
ganzen konfliktes der mit russland hier
entstanden ist und er drängt natürlich
in dieser situation das ist ein
wesentlicher teil seiner strategie
darauf dass sein land westliche partner
hat ja dass er da den rücken gestärkt
bekommt sowohl militärisch als auch auf
politischer ebene
das muss man einfach als sehr sehr
wichtige strategie betrachten und ich
glaube also es ist mein gemüse in den
letzten zwei tagen das bei den ukrainern
auch sehr große enttäuschung darüber
herrscht sie sagen dass im prinzip die
eu und der westen insgesamt nicht genug
für das land hier tut
katrin eigendorf mit einer aktuellen
berichterstattung aus der ukraine ganz
herzlichen dank
auf der anderen seite in moskau tut man
so als wär man eigentlich auch ein opfer
benutzt eine komische sprache und sendet
sehr sehr sehr sehr absurde signale
darüber wollen wir uns unterhalten mit
unserer kollegin anna feist in moskau an
es ist so dass putin
gesprächsbereitschaft signalisiert unter
ganz bestimmten bedingungen wie ernst
muss man dieses angebot nehmen
ja dieses gesprächsangebot
existiert seit dem 1 kriegstag da hat er
sich mittags der belarussische präsident
lukaschenko gemeldet und sagte er habe
mit putin gesprochen und dieser krieg
sei zu stoppen putin habe nur zwei
bedingungen bedingungen nummer eins das
abrücken von einer nato mitgliedschaft
der ukraine und eine komplette
demilitarisierung der ukraine dann
könnte neben friedensgespräche
stattfinden und der vorschlag von
lukaschenko und putin sei die in minsk
stattfinden zu lassen dieses
gesprächsangebot wurde dann alle paar
stunden erneuert durch unterschiedliche
minister und schließlich als gestern
selensky um ein gespräch bat so ist die
russische native hat putin sofort zum
telefonhörer gegriffen lukaschenka
angerufen und eben diese
friedensverhandlungen minsk als ort
dafür klar gemacht daraufhin also auch
wieder russisches narrativ soll aber sie
lenski gesagt haben nein er wolle in
polen in warschau verhandeln und sei
dann nicht mehr ans telefon gegangen
das ist wie gesagt alles die russische
dir das russische negativ die russische
propaganda festhalten kann man
sicherlich dass es kein offenes
gesprächsangebot ist weil es eben an die
zwei bedingungen geknüpft ist anna jetzt
hast du viel erzählt von narrativen also
erzählungen die sozusagen moskau
zeichnet und er benutzt dabei auch immer
wieder eine verhöhnen der ja absurde
sprache so auch gestern als er die
ukrainische führung als bande von
drogenabhängigen bezeichnet als nazis
und das ukrainische militär zum putsch
aufforderte wieso benutzt er diese
rhetorik wieso spricht er so
ja diese rhetorik immerhin hat es
gestern noch gesehen also insbesondere
als er die führung als er sie lenski als
drogenabhängig bezeichnete die geht
zurück auf gerüchte gerüchte die es hier
gibt die hier verbreitet werden seitdem
sie lenski an der macht ist denn es
heißt es wird verbreitet selensky sei
drogenabhängig sei kokainabhängig das
sehe man an seinen augen und an seinen
augen bringen und so sei das nun mal
solecki habe einen schwachen charakter
und selensky würde instrumentalisiert
von ultranationalisten
das dient natürlich der diffamierung und
das ding natürlich dazu hier dem
russischen volk eine begründung zu geben
warum dieser ukrainische präsident
selensky nicht tragbar sei also all das
gute propaganda verbreitet hier seit
jahren über sämtliche staatlichen kanäle
annafest war das mit eindrücken und
einschätzungen aus moskau vielen dank
die ukraine hat ungefähr halb so viele
einwohner wie wir also circa 40
millionen das bedeutet unzählige
menschen die jetzt richtung westen
fliehen viele natürlich erst einmal in
die nachbarländer nach polen ungarn
rumänien moldawien oder in die slowakei
und dort wollen wir jetzt hingehen und
zwar zu unserer kollegin britta hilpert
die die situation dort vor ort an der
grenze zur ukraine beobachtet wo genau
sind sie und kommt dort viele menschen
an
ich bin hier auf der slowakischen seite
der ukrainische stadt osch corot hier
heißt das wir nehmen jetzt also in der
slowakei und ich muss sagen hat es in
den letzten stunden massiv zugenommen an
flüchtlingsströmen man an menschen die
hier ankommen man sieht aber es sind
immer frauen mit kindern die männer
müssen in der ukraine bleiben sie werden
nicht rausgelassen sie sollen dort
bleiben und kämpfen trotzdem wird dort
an der grenze immer noch massiv
kontrolliert also ich habe sogar schon
gehört das zeug kontrollen durchgeführt
wurden aber natürlich werden pässe
registriert auf beiden seiten und erst
dann kommen die leute über das geschieht
immer so schubweise insgesamt sieht man
aber es sind viel mehr als gestern und
wie geht es diesen menschen was brauchen
die jetzt und wie kann man ihnen helfen
also manche die ich hier sehe kommen
rüber und sind einfach am 1 manche sind
sehr gefasst ganz viele suchen einfach
nach weitertransport und das ist
wirklich toll zu sehen was hier passiert
von privater hand muss man sagen ist so
eine art hilfe des cap desg hat sich
hier etabliert das sind privatleute dass
eine gruppe von freunden die sind aus
bratislava einfach gestern hierher
gefahren einfach nur freunde keine
organisation und haben sich hier
angeboten zu helfen transporte ins
inland denn die allermeisten ukraine die
ankommen hat irgendwelche verwandten
irgendwo in tschechien in der slowakei
oder in deutschland suchen einfach nur
weitertransport und diese leute
organisieren dass unbezahlt freiwillig
keine organisation dahinter machen liste
mit telefonnummern und helfen den leuten
einfach weiter insgesamt ist die
hilfsbereitschaft sehr groß viele leute
kommen einfach her mit ihren autos und
sagen wir wollen helfen wir kennen die
man in der ukraine aber in dieser
situation müssen wir helfen und die
hilfe wird gebraucht es wird immer mehr
das spüren wir und viele leute sind
ratlos und wissen gar nicht wie weiter
aber die hilfe ist jetzt noch da der
staat fehlt noch der sollte vielleicht
hier vor ort auch noch ein bisschen mehr
tun britta hilpert war das mit
eindrücken von der ukrainischen grenze
zur slowakei und mitri du machst weiter
mit eindrücken an einer anderen grenze
ja ähnliche situation tatsächlich auch
in polen hariett an der ukrainischen
grenze dort ist mir jetzt natalie steger
zugeschaltet natalie was können sie uns
bericht was erleben sie dort
nun die situation ist ganz ähnlich als
das was britta geschildert hat wir
stehen hier am bahnhof in chemischer
hier kommen noch züge an heute morgen
ein zug aus kiew mit 1000 menschen das
soll den ganzen tag noch vier stunden
alle vier stunden so weitergehen mit
diesem großen zügen zwischenzeitlich und
immer wieder sind die züge sehr
verspätet immer wieder kommt sorge auch
ob die züge überhaupt nicht mehr aus der
ukraine rauskommen aber es sieht noch
ganz gut aus im gegenteil offenbar kommt
man mit dem zug noch zügiger raus als
mit dem auto oder zu fuß denn auf der
anderen seite auf der ukrainischen hören
wir dass man 24 stunden mittlerweile
warten muss eben auto oder zu fuß bis
man die ukraine verlassen kann bei minus
drei grad und wir haben gehört dass dort
menschen kollabieren sie brauchen decken
es sind viele viele kinder dabei also
die situation muss eher dramatisch seien
extreme zustände natalie wie ist
eigentlich polen darauf vorbereitet und
womit rechnet man mit wie vielen
menschen die kurzfristig vielleicht
mittel und langfristig dort zuflucht
finden
ursprünglich es gibt schon sehr lange
notfallpläne da hat sich polen darauf
vorbereitet da hat man von drei bis fünf
millionen flüchtlingen gesprochen die
man aufnehmen könnte das war allerdings
noch der plan bevor diese massive
großoffensive gestartet ist die sich
keiner so richtig vorstellen konnte aber
police darauf vorbereitet hat deloitte
wirtschaften regionen angewiesen zu
helfen wir sehen das auch hier am
bahnhof
überall hilft das militär hilft die
polizei verteilt essen schokolade an die
kinder die privatleute ähnlich wie bei
britta in der slowakei helfen hinter mir
kommt per man in essen an und wir haben
zum beispiel auch mit einer frau
gesprochen aus breslau dies mit ihrer
großen tochter und zwei pkw heute nach
extra hierher gefahren steht jetzt da
und wird menschen transportieren weil
das auch hier das wichtigste ist dass
die menschen weiter kommen sie wird die
menschen zum flughafen in krakau bringen
und auch eine familie nach posen die
hilfsbereitschaft ist auch hier wirklich
gigantisch vielen dank für diese
eindrücke von der polnisch ukrainischen
grenze war dass natalie steger
ja wie reagieren auf den angriff
russlands auf die ukraine damit hat sich
heute nacht auf antrag der usa und
albanien der sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen in new york
beschäftigt ja geplant war eine
resolution gegen den einmarsch in die
ukraine dieses aber dann wenig
überraschend am veto russlands
gescheitert china hat sich enthalten was
die einen als erfolg werten andere
allerdings nicht mehr von johannes hano
es war eine geste der solidarität als
ich kurz vor der sitzung des un
sicherheitsrat ist die botschafter der
europäischen union hinter ihrem
ukrainischen kollegen und seiner fahne
versammelten schon da war klar dass es
eine außergewöhnliche sitzung werden
würde die usa in albanien hatten eine
resolution zur abstimmung eingebracht
die den russischen angriffskrieg in der
ukraine verurteilt aber es ging um sehr
viel mehr
ich sage es ganz offen stimmt mit ja die
charta der vereinten nationen
aufrechterhalten wollen wenn ihr die
souveränität und die territoriale
integrität der ukraine und die jeden
anderen staates unterstützt wenn ihr
überzeugt seid dass russlands präsent
handeln zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
stimmt mit nein oder enthaltung
wenn ihr nicht hinter der charta der
vereinten nationen steht und euch gemein
macht mit dem aggressiven und
provozierten handeln russlands
russland das war klar würde die
resolution mit einem veto belegen
botschafter bezichtigte den westen der
lüge und der propaganda
russische truppen bombardieren keine
ukrainischen städte wir haben gesagt
dass sie nicht bedroht sind es gibt
keine verifizierbare bestätigung über
den tod von zivilisten
die frage war wer wird russland
unterstützen und gegen die resolution
stimmen oder sich enthalten immer wieder
wurde die sitzung verschoben wollten die
usa und andere china und indien
überzeugen der resolution zuzustimmen
ohne erfolg indien die vereinigten
arabischen emirate und china enthielten
sich der stimme
die legitimen sicherheitsbedenken aller
staaten müssen berücksichtigt werden
vor dem hintergrund von fünf
erweiterungsrunden der nato richtung
osten muss man verstehen dass russlands
sicherheitsbedenken berücksichtigt
werden müssen
wir bedanken uns bei denen die diese
resolution nicht unterstützt haben elf
ja stimmen 3 enthaltungen und einer
gegenstimme für die vereinten nationen
und die weltordnung diese repräsentieren
eine zäsur denn das ergebnis macht eines
klar ein völkerrechtswidriger
angriffskrieg wird im sicherheitsrat
nicht mehr von allen staaten abgelegt am
ende der sitzung bat die ukraine um
einige denkt minute für die opfer des
krieges unterbrochen vom russischen
botschafter und mit applaus bedacht von
der mehrheit der anwesenden vertreter
nach dieser denkwürdigen sitzung haben
wir mit johannes hahn droht morgen
gesprochen und natürlich über die
kernfrage wie man dieses ergebnis oder
das votum werden kann
[Musik]
sind die mitglieder des sicherheitsrates
die auf deren aufgabe es ist diese den
weltfrieden herzustellen stehen die noch
hinter der charta der vereinten nationen
oder nicht und insofern war das
abstimmungsergebnis dann doch sehr
interessant elf stände haben für diese
resolution gestimmt aber eben auch drei
haben sich enthalten nämlich china
indien die beiden atommächte und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate dass
russland war klar aber es hat heute
ziemlich klage ist ziemlich klar
geworden muss man sagen dass es eben
wichtige länder in dieser welt gibt die
einen angriffskrieg nicht mehr ablehnen
als mittel der politik das muss man so
sagen ja
gestern abend auch ein weiterer
sondergipfel bei der nato einheiten von
der sogenannten schnellen einsatztruppe
werden in die östlichen mitgliedsländer
verlegt übrigens zum ersten mal dass
teile dieser truppe zur abschreckung und
verteidigung des bündnisses verlegt
werden so generalsekretär stoltenberg er
zeigt bei der suche nach einer richtigen
antwort aktuell geht es zum einen darum
wie tritt man nach außen also gegenüber
putin auf aber eben auch welches signal
sendet man nach in andy ost europäischen
bündnispartner nämlich damit die sich
eben gut geschützt fühlen um druck auf
russland ausüben sind in dieser nacht
dieser neuen eu sanktionen in kraft
getreten mehr dazu erfahren wir von anne
gellinek
schon dreimal haben die europäischen
außenminister und ministerinnen in
dieser woche zusammen gesessen zwei
sanktionspaket gegen russland
beschlossen und sich dann noch wladimir
putin und sergey lavrov vorgeknöpft
neben dem belarussischen diktator ist
putin nun der einzige präsident der welt
gegen den die eu sanktionen verhängt hat
sie sind verantwortlich dafür dass
unschuldige menschen in der ukraine
sterben sie sind dafür verantwortlich
dass das internationale system mit füßen
getreten wird und das nehmen wir als
europäerinnen und europäer nicht hin
darüber hinaus beschließt die eu ihre
bislang härtesten strafmaßnahmen
ihr ziel die russische wirtschaft
langfristig zu schwächen im paket
exportkontrollen für flugzeugtechnik gas
und ölförderung high tech produkte
außerdem listet die eu drei große
russische banken die künftig keine
geschäfte mehr in europa machen sollen
putin und lavrov dürfen übrigens weiter
in die europäische union einreisen
schließlich gibt es die hoffnung dass
man nach kriegsende wieder miteinander
reden können aber noch ist es nicht
soweit fünf kilometer vom europaviertel
entfernt krisen video konferenz der
nato-mitglieder die militärallianz
beschließt die so genannte schnelle
eingreiftruppe zu verlegen um die
ostflanke zu stärken wie fielmann und
wohin ist unklar das ziel deutlich
abschreckung
ist für uns ist wichtig dass wir ein
überschwappen des furchtbaren und
inakzeptablen angriffs auf die ukraine
ein überschwappen auf einen nato partner
verhindern
und um dafür zu sorgen dass es keine
missverständnisse oder
fehleinschätzungen gibt hat die nato
ihre präsenz im östlichen teil der
allianz verstärkt mit kampftruppen die
wir an die ostflanke verlegen
draußen vom hauptquartier demonstrieren
den ganzen tag lang menschen mit
ukrainischen fan sie wünschen sich einen
baldigen nato beitritt ihres landes die
demonstranten dürfen nur auf der anderen
straßenseite stehen die nato hält sie
wie das land auf abstand
ja was kann deutschland in dieser
dramatischen lage eigentlich tun wie
können wir den menschen helfen dabei
geht es in erster linie jetzt darum die
die flüchtlinge empfangen und versorgen
können und in berlin zum beispiel hat
das bereits begonnen wie roman disco war
berichtet
berlins ankunft zentrum für flüchtlinge
am nachmittag die ersten ukraine sind da
erkannt werden wollen sie nicht auch
nicht wirklich mit uns reden aus kiew
sind sie erzählen sie lediglich als
normale touristen kamen sie vor dem
kriegsausbruch nach deutschland jetzt
sind sie hier gestrandet zurück wollen
sie auf keinen fall
die vorbereitungen auf eine mögliche
ukrainische flüchtlingswelle laufen in
berlin auf hochtouren fürs wochenende
steht diese erste aufnahme einrichtung
zur verfügung danach soll es eine neue
bleibe geben heißt es aus der verwaltung
vom bund fordert man nicht nur offene
aufenthaltsrechtliche fragen zügig zu
klären was auf jeden fall bestandteil
dieser entscheidung sein muss ist dass
die kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine
gleich von anfang an eine
arbeitsgenehmigung haben denn das sind
menschen die teilweise von ihren
arbeitsstätten mit ihren familien in die
autos gestiegen sind und jetzt vor
bomben und bodentruppen fliehen
andernorts versucht man die menschen im
kriegsgebiet zu unterstützen die ukraine
hilfe berlin sammelt schon seit den
massenprotesten medikamente
medizinisches gerät für krankenhäuser
oder kinderheime die ehrenamtlichen
mitarbeiter stammen selbst aus der
ukraine mehr hilfe sei jetzt nötig sagen
sie gleichzeitig werde der transport
schwieriger denn bislang habe man eigene
fahrer in die heimat schicken können
ich habe gefunden aber
ein zeichen gegen den krieg wollten am
abend schließlich berliner chöre setzen
direkt vor dem brandenburger tor riefen
sie dazu auf solidarität mit der ukraine
zu zeigen der schock sitzt immer noch
tief
wir konnten uns das alle nicht
vorstellen
und jetzt müssen wir einfach einsehen
dass es eben leider doch tatsache
geworden ist und dafür einstehen dass es
wieder ausser es kann nicht sein dass so
etwas auf der auf der weltbühne passiert
und wir alle stumm daneben sind und
deswegen erheben wir heute hier unsere
stimme gemeinsam stimmten die gekommenen
lieder an in der hoffnung auf einen
baldigen frieden
[Musik]
ja die ukraine nur ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer können jede hilfe gebrauchen
und wenn sie unterstützen möchten dann
können sie das tun beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe unter dem stichwort
zdf nothilfe ukraine und die iban lautet
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 und alle
infos natürlich auch unter spenden punkt
zdf.de oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio
variiert von waldenfels und mitri sirin
ja und das darf man durchaus als
historisch einordnen dass das
morgenmagazin auch am wochenende sendet
dazu haben sich zdf und ard entschlossen
wir senden seit 7 uhr noch bis 10 30
live morgen übernehmen dann die kollegen
der ard ab 7 uhr der krieg russlands auf
die gegen die ukraine unvermindert geht
er weiter wir sehen jetzt in bilder von
ungefähr 20
helikoptern die
von blister bitzer in richtung hier
fliegen das ist eine aufnahme die ein
ukrainer mit der welt über das internet
teilt und es gibt natürlich jede menge
bilder die auch im internet kursieren
unter anderem diese hier mit
sturmgewehren bewaffnete freiwillige
kämpfer da sehen wir sie die
patrouillierten am freitag also gestern
im zentrum von kiew und sind offenbar
bereit irland zu verteidigen
gedreht wurden diese bilder im übrigen
von kollegen der new york times
aufsehenerregend ist ein tweet den der
präsident der ukraine geteilt hat ihn
vor wenigen stunden oder minuten wir
können ich kann das jetzt gar nicht
genau sagen aber er fordert die aufnahme
seines landes in die eu
das hat
dann der ratspräsident der eu sogar
gerät bietet über twitter charlie shell
und das ist sehr sehr interessant er
sagt dann das ist da noch unterstützung
geben wird da sagt michael hier sehen
wir den tweet von russlands von ukraine
präsidenten seelen ski und charly
schildern um das vielleicht auch noch zu
ergänzen schrieb uk netz people of
family also wir sind quasi eine familie
förder konkret support ist on its way
also weitere unterstützung ist in der
planung werfen wir an dieser stelle
einen blick auf die heutigen gespräche
die wir geführt haben und zwar mit schon
gesprochen mit sergey lagodinsky dem
russland politischen sprecher der grünen
fraktion im eu parlament sowie auch mit
dem neuen csu generalsekretär stephan
mayer und in wenigen augenblicken dann
ein gespräch geplant mit oliver müller
von der caritas international er hat
viele mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
in der akura ii ne wir wollen fragen wie
es denen geht und wie man den menschen
vor ort helfen kann wir fassen die
nachrichtenlage jetzt kurz und kompakt
den heute express zusammen und übergeben
zug soll richter guten morgen hallo
vielen dank ihr beide guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir schauen
zunächst auf die situation in der
ukraine selbst wo auch rund um die
hauptstadt kiew gekämpft wird nach
behördenangaben gibt es in mehreren
stadtteilen straßenkämpfe und beschuss
die bevölkerung soll schutzräume
aufsuchen und dort bleiben präsident
jens gemeldete sich am morgen erneut mit
einer video botschaft darin forderte er
die menschen zum durchhalten auf er
selbst werde auf jeden fall in kiew
im un-sicherheitsrat ist eine resolution
gescheitert die den angriff auf die
ukraine verurteilen sollte wie erwartet
legte russland bei der abstimmung ein
veto ein china indien und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate
enthielten sich die restlichen elf
staaten stimmten für den text
die nato verstärkt ihre ostflanke weiter
so will deutschland eine kompanie in die
slowakei verlegen der vorsitzende des
bundeswehrverbands wüstner hat dem zdf
morgenmagazin ein sofortprogramm
gefordert um die bundeswehr besser
auszurüsten
außerdem müsse der verteidigungsetat
erneut aufgestockt werden die politik
müsse jetzt endlich aufwachen
unterdessen verhandeln moskau und kiew
über direkte gespräche dabei geht es vor
allem um den ort des treffens russland
hatte die belarussische hauptstadt minsk
vorgeschlagen was die ukrainische
regierung ablehnt nun hat sich ungarn
als gastgeber angeboten
zehntausende sind bereits vor den
kämpfen geflüchtet allein nach polen
seien in den vergangenen 24 stunden
35.000 menschen gekommen so die
regierung in warschau auch an der
ukrainisch slowakischen wenn zu
versammeln sich viele die sich in
sicherheit bringen wollen
schauen wir noch kurz aus dem akku oder
denn heute starten die ersten nowaks
impfungen und zwar in hamburg
schleswig-holstein und dem saarland das
wachsen soll vorrangig beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen angeboten werden dort
gilt ab mitte märz eine einrichtung
bezogene impfpflicht als sogenannter
protein impfstoff bietet nowaks
denjenigen eine alternative die der m
rna technologie skeptisch
gegenüberstehen
wenigstens ein lichtblick heute die
sonne scheint benjamin stufe sagt die
denn wann und wo
[Musik]
vielen dank herr server und guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen zum wetter ja im
osten wird es noch ein bisschen dauern
aber je länger der tag frau hat
schreitet desto mehr kann sich das
hochdruckgebiet durchsetzen der vorschau
film zeigt uns das sehr schön von der
biscaya über frankreich weiter nach
mitteleuropa com enthält ist den
tiefdruckeinfluss auch abstand
allerdings an der ostseite dieses
hochdruckgebiet kommt noch die kalte
luft des nordens in unsere richtung
voran also kühl wird heute sein aber er
reden wir später es wird auch um so
sonnig und so starten wir aktuell in den
tag minus drei grad meldet balderschwang
im oberallgäu sechs grad plus sind es
auf norderney heute morgen mit dem
teilweise noch nebel im westen dem
hochnebel im osten ist überfrierende
nässe ein thema gerade in den regionen
denen die temperaturen bei um die null
grad liegen seien sie vorsichtig wenn
sie sich jetzt auf den weg machen und
hier ist der vormittag im überblick da
sehen wir schon sehr viel sonnenschein
vor allem richtung nordwesten im stau
des erzgebirges und im stau der alpen
verklingen die letzten schnee
beziehungsweise schneeregenschauer der
nacht und dann wird es auch im osten
immer freundlicher die wolkendecke reißt
auf die sonne lässt sich blicken den
meisten sonnenschein gibt es heute
richtung nordwesten und richtung
südwesten bei tageshöchsttemperaturen
zwischen 2 grad richtung alpenrand bis
10 grad verbreitet im nordwesten und
damit sind wir bei den hochdruck
geprägten aussichten für die kommenden
tage morgen nach hochnebel auflösung
auch im osten sehr freundlich vier bis
elf grad die gibt es ebenfalls am montag
gleiche wettersituation am dienstag auch
erst mal freundlich aber im tagesverlauf
von nordwesten dichtere wolken und
schauer soweit zum wetter für den moment
kommen sie wird diesen aussichten jetzt
gut in das wochenende
[Musik]
vielen dank an benjamin von uns an
diesen auch denkwürdigen samstag einen
guten tag und willkommen nochmal im
russischen angriffskrieg konzentrieren
sich die kämpfe gerade auf die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew ja und auch
in dieser nacht gab es schüsse es gibt
sie weiterhin kämpfe am stadtrand
präsident sehr lynskey aber auch der
bürgermeister von kiew vitali klitschko
rief die bewohner auf die stadt zu
verteidigen ja und offenbar auch dass
die führungen in kiew und moskau sind
gerade in kontakt über gespräche
russlands präsident putin hat sie lenski
ein gespräch in weißrussland angeboten
allerdings nicht er persönlich sondern
eine russische delegation
außenministerin annalena baerbock nannte
das gesprächsangebot vergiftet nun wir
wissen jetzt nicht wie das ganze weiter
geht es sind jetzt quasi verhandlungen
über verhandlungen denn putin stellte
bestimmte bedingungen die man im grunde
natürlich nicht akzeptieren kann er will
minsk als verhandlungsort also
weißrussland von dort sind russische
truppen hinein in die ukraine es geht
also faktisch gar nicht und die aktuelle
lage über die geschehnisse der nacht und
der letzten stunde annette streicher und
tim kröger fassen sie zusammen
ein loch klafft in diesem wohnhaus nahe
des flughafens am südwestrand von kiew
verwüstete geschäfte nach einem
raketeneinschlag und doch ist ein neuer
morgen in der hauptstadt angebrochen an
dem die straßen noch unter kontrolle der
ukraine sind in der nacht durchbrachen
einschläge die stille immer näher am
zentrum der unabhängigkeitsplatz wie
lange kann er noch verteidigt werden am
abend hatte der ukrainische präsident
seine bürger auf entscheidende stunden
vorbereitet wir dürfen unsere hauptstadt
nicht verlieren appellierte er obwohl er
selbst um sein leben fürchten muss nach
der dämmerung macht er hoffnung mit
einer neuen videobotschaft
wir werden die waffen nicht niederlegen
wir werden unseren staat verteidigen
sagt er
kiew das hauptziel der russischen
invasion die russischen einheiten rücken
vor allem von norden an die stadt heran
der kreml wolle die ukrainische führung
ablösen und eine marionettenregierung
installieren so die lesart vieler
beobachter am späten abend schildert ein
notfallmediziner aus kiew im zdf die
situation
haben können sie uns sagen wie viele
opfer des krieges sie jetzt bereits
behandeln mussten in der staat erhört
man dass geschossen wird und
man hört auch explosionen
weil wir haben einen improvisierten
bunker leider müssen die bettlägerigen
patienten in den zimmern bleiben
und wir bieten immer an den gott dass er
kein geschoss zu uns kommt ein winziger
hoffnungsschimmer vielleicht laut
facebook seite eines sprechers der
ukrainischen führung werde gerade mit
den russen über mögliche verhandlungen
verhandelt ausgang noch immer ungewiss
noch aber ist das die realität
russische truppen greifen die ukraine
von mehreren seiten an aktiv etwa
stellen sich ihnen ukrainische soldaten
entgegen dass detonationen in der nähe
angst auf den straßen
dieser vater zeigt wie der vorhang seine
tochter vor den zersplitternden fenstern
bewahrt habe
wir mussten in der u-bahn-station
schlafen es war sehr voll menschen saßen
auf stühlen wir blieben an einem platz
weil dort ein weißer hund war den mochte
ich sehr
fahrradhelme gegen bomben u bahnhöfe und
heizungskeller werden zu schutzräumen
viele sehen nur noch die flucht als
ausweg nach einschätzung der vereinten
nationen versuchen derzeit
hunderttausende noch das land zu
verlassen der präsident bleibt hat
us-amerikanischen informationen zufolge
abgelehnt sich in sicherheit bringen zu
lassen wohl mit den worten er brauche
munition keine mitfahrgelegenheit
unterdessen hat der us-präsident den weg
frei gemacht für über 300 millionen euro
militärischer soforthilfe etwa
zeitgleich konnte die ukrainische armee
einen russischen konvoi vor kiew stoppen
der widerstand geht weiter
schalten wir live zu katrin eigendorf
zugeschaltet aus der ukraine kathrin
gestern haben ja viele befürchtet hier
würde in nur wenigen stunden fallen und
von russischen truppen erobert werden
aber es gibt widerstand und damit hatte
putin so in dieser form vielleicht gar
nicht gerechnet welche informationen
haben sie aktuell
es gibt sehr großen widerstand und es
ist ja auch so dass sich eine stadt wie
kiew nicht alleine aus der luft erobern
lässt die russen haben zu anfang des
krieges also am ersten kriegstag große
erfolge militärische erfolge erzielt
indem sie vor allem aus der luft
ukrainische stellungen bombardiert haben
aber um die stadtkirche es wirklich zu
erobern müssen sie natürlich mit
bodentruppen in die stadt rein gehen da
sind sie wohl mit einem sehr sehr großen
widerstand nicht nur der ukrainischen
streitkräfte sondern auch der
bevölkerung konfrontiert also es
gestaltet sich zunehmend schwierig für
putin seine strategie zu verfolgen in
kiew die regierung zu entmachten
denn auch sie lenski der ukrainische
präsident ruft immer wieder auch in sehr
sehr emotionalen ansprachen die
bevölkerung zum widerstand auf auch wenn
er sicherlich der gefährdetste in dieser
krise im moment ist will er in der stadt
bleiben
wir haben aus regierungskreisen gehört
dass die russen sogenannte schwarze
listen haben auf denen sie die topleute
der ukrainischen regierung als hauptziel
vermerken das ist natürlich eine sehr
bedrohliche lage aber ich denke wladimir
putin muss damit rechnen dass er kiew
nur erobern kann wenn es dazu wirklich
zu einem sehr schlimmen blutbad kommt
und das wird sich nicht so schnell
realisieren lassen präsident selensky
hat sich ja in wiederholten
videobotschaften auch in der letzten
zeit an die öffentlichkeit gewandt
insbesondere mithilfe besuchen an den
westen und hat jetzt in einem tweet auch
die aufnahme in die eu gefordert was ist
das für eine strategie
das ist seit langem die strategie des
ukrainischen präsidenten sein land in
westliche bündnisse zu integrieren in
die nato in die eu die ukraine sieht
sich unter dieser regierung und ja schon
seit langem im prinzip auf dem weg in
den westen das ist ja eigentlich die
hauptursache auch für den krieg den
wladimir putin gegen dieses land führt
er will im prinzip die westintegration
der ukraine verhindern
selent sqeez strategie in diesen letzten
tagen ist noch einmal besonders darauf
zu drängen dass der westen an der seite
der ukraine ist er macht immer wieder
darauf aufmerksam
ja wir stehen im prinzip hier auch für
westliche werte für die konfrontation
auch die putin insgesamt mit dem westen
hier auf ukrainischem boden sucht und
wir bemerken doch auch eine große
enttäuschung hier nicht nur in
regierungskreisen sondern teilweise auch
von der bevölkerung man erwartet auch
vom westen mehr unterstützung in der
aktuellen situation katrin eigendorf
passen sie und ihr team bitte weiter gut
auf sich auch wir bedanken uns ganz
herzlich für diese berichterstattung
und wollen von der ukraine nach russland
gehen genauer nach moskau dort für uns
seit tagen ist anna fast noch meinen
guten morgen nach moskau es gibt gestern
ja
meldungen bzw sie haben das sogar
gesehen dass putin sich an die ukraine
gewarnt hat an das ukrainische militär
und zwar mit drastischen worten absurde
worte er hat die ukrainische führung als
drogenabhängig bezeichnet als neonazis
und das kann man ja eigentlich nur
kopfschüttelnd mit mit kopfschütteln
quittieren die frage ist wieso spricht
er so und kaufen ihm das eigentlich die
landsleute ab die russinnen und russen
ja diese gerüchte dass präsident
selensky er drogenabhängig sei dieses
gerücht hält sich schon seit vielen
vielen jahren und wird schon seit vielen
jahren verbreitet es geht darauf zurück
dass man ihm unterstellt eben auch hier
im russischen staatsfernsehen
er sei kokain abhängig das sehe man eben
auch an seinen augen und an seinen